foreign
good morning everybody it is 9 30. I am
going to open the executive session for
house bill 97.
establishing an additional penalty for
violation of privacy
and we will be in recess for I'm going
to call it 10 minutes because we are
waiting for
okay we were waiting for one more member
but at this point we're just going to go
ahead and exec the the first want to see
what happens
so I am opening the executive session on
HB 97fn and I am recognizing
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
.
I was about to yes
no worries yes thank you
thank you Mr chairman as we heard in
committee uh House Bill 97 is not
creating a new law it is simply
addressing the unlawful and
non-consensual violation of someone's
privacy
um and let's stress that this is for
repeat offenders and we are simply
trying to help these victims from
representative Murphy would you like to
speak to you a second
foreign
a great synopsis of of the point of of
this bill and and uh certainly think
that uh we need to pass it for
um the uh protection of people that's
it's violated the uh privacy just is
being consistently violated
they're being none the clerk will call
um Vice chair Rhodes yes
uh representative Pratt yes
representative wood
yes
representative pruell
uh representative Manion
yes
representative Reed
representative Stone
yes
representative tenzar
representative Harriet gothright
representative Schultz yes
representative Bolden
yes
representative Bradley
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes yay
representative Newell
yes
representative selig yes
representative wheeler yay
all right the total vote is 19.
chairman
I'll close the executive session on HP
97.
this time I will open the executive
I recommend recognize representative
Reed for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move that house
would you like to speak to your motion
after hearing testimony on House Bill
560 it is a win-win bill that will
assist both law enforcement and citizens
and encounters with police officers I
see no downside to this bill
representative Murphy would you like to
speak to you a second
um yes I think this is a phenomenal Bill
and has such great potential to help law
enforcement and those with disabilities
in our communities um I I think this
will save lives
thank you
any discussion
I would just add that this is one of the
best bills I've ever seen since being
here so I don't know what took us so
long to think of it but I'm glad we
found we finally did the clerk will call
the roll
Vice chair Rhodes
yes
representative Pratt
representative wood
yes
representative pruell
representative Prue votes yes
uh representative Manion
yes
representative Reed
representative Stone
yes
representative tensar
representative Harriet gothright
representative Schultz yes
representative Bolden
yes
representative Bradley
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes
representative selig yes
representative wheeler yay
and chair Roy yeah
Chapel CS
19-0
motion passes
no objection to consent and
I hereby close the executive session HP
560 and the committee will be in recess
it being 10 45 I'm going to open the
public hearing on HP 498 and recognize
thank you chairman members of the
committee for the record representative
hole
serving the towns of Dunbarton hooks at
Allentown and epsom known as Merrimack
27 here to testify in favor of House
Bill 498 relative to changes about
whether
our fish and game conservation officers
would require a warrant
um to do certain searches part of this
stems back to a change in the law under
section 206 26 normally this would be a
phishing gain build
and that section is the powers of the
officers of Fish and Game and I'm going
to read write a little bit of that as an
introduction because that will help
explain the rationale for the bill
206 26 Powers the executive director is
certified as a police officer in
accordance with RSA 106-l colon 5 Roman
numeral 5 and each conservation officer
shall have the following powers to
enforce all laws rules and regulations
relating to all wildlife
I'm going to say that again relating to
all Wildlife to go on any property
outside the buildings posted or
otherwise
Roman numeral two to execute all
warrants in search warrants based on
probable cause for the violation of laws
rules and regulations relating to
Wildlife
so we understand that their job is
regarding wildlife
however a couple years ago we added to
enforce all provisions of RSA title 21
relative to Motor Vehicle Laws absent
any violation or suspected violation of
so we have our conservation officers
enforcing DMV laws absent fishing game
loss
I thought we hired them to handle Fish
and Game loss
not to be super cops
so the problem is since we've given them
the authority to do warrantless searches
in clear violation of both the U.S
Constitution
Bill of Rights
uh article 6 if I were
recall the right of the people to be
secure in their persons houses papers
and effects against unreasonable
searches and seizures shall not be
violated and no warrant shall issue but
and there's a similar provision in part
first article
19 of the New Hampshire Constitution
almost verbatim language
why do we allow one particular set of
Fish and Game officers to have greater
Authority
than the state police greater Authority
than any police officer in any Town
within the state
if we fix the section about enforcement
of DMV laws it wouldn't be as bad an
issue
I can understand the argument it's
really hard to get a warrant when you're
in the middle of a lake got it let's
have that discussion okay you can tell
the person right I want to search your
your Bait Box I want to search right
your fish container I understand that
okay the person can say I want to see a
Warren and the Fish and Game officer can
say great understand there's a huge time
hit when we do this conversation because
I'm going to call in and get someone
else to come
and they're going to have to then go get
a warrant so plan for a six or eight
hour exchange but the person has that
right
that's in the Constitution we don't just
give those rights up now the person may
yield that right and that is within
their power to say oh I don't mind you
searching there's nothing in the in the
bait box or nothing in in in my fish
container that would be
um prohibited anyway right I'm not using
the wrong type of lures I'm not using
the these aren't lead or whatever the
concern is right there's lots of fishing
game laws I'm not not going to be
pretend to be an expert on all the fish
and game laws
but our laws should support the
underlying structure and agreement that
our entire State and country was founded
upon which is the Constitution and in
this case we have a knowingly a vial a
statute that knowingly violates right
the warrant claw the search warrant
Clause so all this bill does is insist
that the officer seek a warrant
understand that those in the field right
who
um the conservation officers approached
can waive that right that is their
choice
if they waive that right it doesn't
change anything about how a search would
be conducted but they do have the right
the problem is
because we've expanded their authority
over the years to be more than just
conservation officers they are now
effectively State Police and in and
charged with enforcing the DMV laws they
can pull someone over on the side of the
road and say I'm searching your car and
the person doesn't have the right to say
no I'd like to see a warrant and one
could make the argument if you're on a
major highway and you're enforcing DMV
laws the ability to get a warrant just
like the state police would have to do
is pretty easy so with that I'll
representative do you have any um
any ideas about why that power was
granted to them regarding the motor
vehicles I understand that they're
oftentimes Motor Vehicles involved in
Fish and Game Vehicles hunting from a
vehicle or it shouldn't be
but remember as I read that law it's not
in violation of a fish and game law it
is beyond that if there was a vehicle in
efficient game incident someone was was
presumed to be shooting a firearm from a
car right that would be handled very
differently than enforcing a speeding
write a speeding violation right or
um
I don't I don't drink much but I'm going
to use drinking as a good example I know
it's a bad one given that there's
there's a lot of pushback but someone
crosses a yellow line or wavers across
the white line and the officer suspects
that the person was drinking and pulls
them over and starts searching the car
for alcohol right I'm pretty certain the
person's right constitutional rights
were violated now ordinarily they would
just say hey no there's no alcohol in
the car and if you want to search you
can get a warrant
I don't know if anybody's watched the
cars on the sides of the roads that are
being searched but pretty much all the
contents of the car and are strewn about
and it's a pretty invasive thing
we ordinarily protect our citizens
against such invasions okay unless
there's probable cause which is what the
grounds necessary for a warrant
um
it's okay to say to somebody yes I'd
like you to get a warrant before you
perceive and if there's probable cause a
judge will sign that pretty quickly
within within an hour it might mean that
the conservation officer is sitting on
the side of the road for a little bit
longer I get that that is a that delay
means that person isn't on the job
enforcing other things during that time
however
um we have a set of rules which for the
Constitution by what our democracy
follows to make sure the role of
government is understood and when we
have statutes that violate those
constitutional Provisions it is our job
as state legislators to fix that
so is is it your understanding of the
current state of the law that
the fish and game officers are not
required to follow the same in other
words if an officer pulls over someone
and says hey do you mind if I take a
look in the car and the guy says no
pound saying get a warrant they have to
get a warrant unless there's excellent
circumstances that is true for the State
Police is it your position that they can
say well no you don't get to say no get
out I'm searching your car that is that
is the provisions today between the
combination of this section of law here
right because we're all we're all in 206
26 and it's easy to look at the changes
and go oh this doesn't make any sense
that's why I wanted some context
relative to the rest of the changes we
added it Roman numeral 15.
I want to say it was in the last 10
years I the when I looked back it looks
like it was in 2017 but I didn't go back
and actually look for what gear that
bill went through
we added Provisions to the law that
greatly expanded their powers much
greater so
than all the other officers law
enforcement officers in the state and
and that's where the conflict arises I
understand why those had these these
rules were in place for the person out
on the middle of Lake Winnipesaukee
right there's only one vote in the right
that the conservation officer has he's
pulled somebody over he what is he going
to jump in the boat or the guys pulled
over and and wait for his friend to run
out to get a warrant and come back and
there are there are technical
difficulties in the field those
technical difficulties don't exist when
thank you for your testimony
has there been any cases of that
happening
that's a great question
um I don't spend my time in the
courtroom so I don't know but I can
um at least inquire of some of the
attorneys that I do know whether that
has been the case
um the problem is it
even if there has been no cases the
statutes allow for such a case and it's
not a corner case
um as you move further north in the
state especially above the notch right
Fish and Game officers are going to be
asked to do more and
um we all know there's hiring issues
today local police departments are
having trouble getting people State
Police are having trouble getting people
you could imagine a case where
a current officer in a different
department is going to be called in to
do some enforcement and we've allowed a
unconstitutional or a case where we can
violate the constitution and I think we
should leave that sacrifanct our our
constitutional protections especially in
thank you
next
Gina Gino the chair recognizes Mr Gino
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Geno maricone and I
am the chairman of the marine fisheries
advisory committee uh which is a
statutory committee and we advise New
Hampshire fishing game department on
marine fisheries and Coastal issues down
on the Seacoast
um
we're we're in opposition to this mainly
because we we work very closely with
Fish and Game including law enforcement
uh they attend all of our meetings we
have discussions they tell us what's
going on and for those of us that are on
the committee uh we're represented by
commercial fishermen recreational
fishermen Seafood dealers chatter boat
fishermen and
we know how important it is that the law
enforcement with Fish and Game have the
ability to board votes uh out at sea
uh under the conditions that go on out
at sea to be able to patrol the Seacoast
area and when they observe uh people
engaged in activities of harvesting or
transporting marine species they need
the ability to inspect that those
species marine species are highly
regulated
item here in all of New England and we
just think that this would not allow the
department to carry out its mission of
protecting that species and and carrying
out and forcing the regulations that are
set in statute and in administrative
rules
there are other people that want to
good morning thank you for this
good morning my name is Eric Anderson
thank you for this opportunity to speak
um in opposition to this bill
um I represent myself and also I am
president of the New Hampshire
commercial Fisherman's Association and
um as my other colleagues come forward I
think we're all in opposition of this
bill
um
I've had over 40 years of experience of
on the water and and it's with respect
and admiration
um that I've observed the conduct of New
Hampshire Fish and Game officers they
they conduct themselves in a very
professional manner
um
and they do have a difficult job and so
having this provision that they've been
allowed it's it's been to my knowledge
that they've never that they just don't
abuse it they recognize the privilege
they do not abuse it in any way shape in
a manner
um and it's a necessary component of
um
how they were going to enforce and
protect our natural resources in the
state especially on the water I think
you've you've heard the description of
you know the difficulty of what the what
what what it would entail to get a
warrant while they are on the water and
the the operational problems it would
that would be created by that
um
I've scratched a lot of hair off my head
as you can see through the course of my
time I can relate and I'm just
bewildered that that this is not the
first time or occasion that we've come
before this you know come to Concord to
oppose this to oppose this type of Bill
and I think you have to um
you have to give you know the New
Hampshire Fish and Game officers every
ability to do their job under difficult
situations
give you a testimony
ah good morning
um my name is Kyle Baker and I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation the Hampshire Wildlife
Federation is an association that
represents about 50 organizations across
the state involved in outdoor recreation
and Hunting Fishing and trapping
um groups like The New Hampshire
Trappers Association the bear hunters
Association and about 50 different uh in
particular uh shooting and Fish and Game
clubs around the state
um we're here in opposition to the bill
I'm also handing around a letter right
now for some folks that also oppose the
bill that couldn't be here today
including the Timberland Owners
Association trout unlimited Ducks
Unlimited the New Hampshire Farm Bureau
the off highway vehicle association uh
the guides Association more sporting
goods and a society protection of New
Hampshire Forest who all asked to be on
the record as opposing this piece of
legislation
um uh I read them out loud simply
because we are the regulative community
the community that interacts with fish
and game on a daily basis
and we have some strong concerns about
this piece of legislation as we see it
as uh a removal of the collaboration
that our organizations have had with the
department for many years and decades
um leave back to the 30s when this
statute was put in place we see this
bill as a way to that would increase
potential poaching in New Hampshire and
potential other high levels of risk that
would put together that would risk the
record populations and strong habitats
we have in New Hampshire uh the last
multiple Years you'll hear from folks
behind me we've had record deer seasons
record bear seasons record turkey
seasons um you know there was a time
where we had no turkeys left in New
Hampshire where there's a time we had no
beavers left in New Hampshire and it's
the sportsmen working together with fish
and game that's allowed these
populations to rebound and the habitats
to continue to be able to support them
so with that I want to be very
respectful of your time there's a lot of
folks here to speak but I encourage you
to reach out to any of these
organizations if you have more specific
questions about sort of their impact in
opposition to the Bell but I'm happy to
answer any questions that folks might
have
uh good morning Mike Flanagan Ryan New
Hampshire
I've been a full-time commercial
fisherman in New Hampshire for 67 years
I've never had a Fisheries violation
I've never had a motor vehicle violation
my wife and I sent three kids to private
college
I've I started a 14-foot boat progressed
on up to a 65-foot boat now I'm down to
42 foot boat
I have a 1200 trap license my brother
also has a 1200 trap license my two sons
on a piece of waterfront property a
wholesale Lobster buying and shipping
business in Kittery
where I'm way over capitalized in the
fishing industry and I can't imagine
you're taking enforcement things away
from the game wardens I thought they
used to be federally deputized the game
one to my friends are the only
protection I have
and it scares me to think
we're talking about you talk about trap
numbers you people don't realize how
expensive our traps are it makes no
sense to me what I do when my I don't
fish 1200 traps anymore you have a 1200
trap license lobster traps now are over
150 a piece
the only protection I have is the game
wardens I remember the Wild and Woolly
days when I started you people don't
ever want to see that come back again
but we the game wants to eat all the
enforcement rights you can give them
state waters and federal waters I mean
it's it's we're not talking about
catching one more trout of this and then
lobster fishing is the only economical
viable business left in New Hampshire
there are a few young people getting
into it and need all the protection you
can give them it's the only thing people
got left to do
and there's some serious issues in the
lobster history right now but we need
all the protection we can get
thank you very much if any questions I'd
representative
thank you for taking my
thank you so much for the work you do
and and for supporting sustainable
sustaining fishing practices I'm curious
if if this were to be enacted and you
were out or about to head out to to go
check your traps and were held back for
however long it took to get a warrant
what would that do as in terms of an
impact or if you were out at Sea and
stopped for for checking for and had to
wait several hours for enforcement it's
ridiculous
it's really ridiculous like I can't
imagine anybody's proposing this we're a
business you know it's like anyone else
you start in the morning you have to
produce every day and to stop someone
for any period of time just because you
want to stop them that's ridiculous you
know our days are very limited
weather-wise opportunities we have to
complete the day the ones
they're friends of mine they come aboard
my boat anytime they want they've never
held me up for any reason
Fallout for clarification
what I meant is if if this were passed
and you had to wait two hours while they
obtained a warrant
how would that impact what happened to
your business it would be terrible I'd
lose 25 or 30 of my income that
particular day we don't we don't get
paid
trying to make a point here we don't get
paid for being there
I get paid every day for what goes on
the scale to a tenth of a pound
if I caught 100 pounds yesterday if that
so be it if I don't go today at zero if
I go get 50 pounds
that's exactly what goes on the scale we
get paid every day for what goes on the
scale we don't get paid for being there
we don't get paid for sick days holidays
vacations we get paid to produce that's
it
thank you
I can't claim 67 years I've only got 60
plus I'm the Junior
um
decided with me if you're three years
no as my brother said we we've seen the
the best and the worst of it
um
the wardens are necessary
part of our occupation
um
I would hate to see them handcuffed
I trust them to be professional and to
do what they believe is right
like any profession there there are bad
apples
but they all aren't bad apples if you
find a bad apple you deal with it
individually
um
I've spoken well
because of where we fish we're subject
to three different sets of laws we're
subject to Federal Regulation
we're subject to Maine regulation and
we're subject to New Hampshire
regulation
so idea say
there's probably no industry in this
country that's as highly regulated as
if we are left to enforce those
regulations on our own we go back to the
law of the jungle
that's not going to be good for anybody
as my brother said we're we're all over
capitalized
we can't afford to do that we've got too
much to lose
so we depend on the wardens to be out
there be visible
just their presence and the the
visibility is a big part of their job if
people see them and know they're out
there that's almost as good as boarding
if they suspect something there's some
issue I encourage them to board
immediately
where we are in the weather conditions
I don't want to lay there for three or
four hours freshen my ass off waiting
for somebody to come get get the warrant
um it's it's dangerous it's unproductive
um
I'm afraid if you take disability away
from them what's going to happen next
are we going to put them
we're going to take their patrol
Vehicles away and put them in roller
skates and paddle boards I mean you
can't limit their ability to do their
job
so I would encourage you to
to reject this proposal
they have a very unique job and a very
unique
conditions
I think that needs to be recognized and
give them the latitude to do their job
so we in the industry certainly
appreciate it and as I say without it it
goes back to the law of the Jungle and
that's going to be bad for everybody
thank you
foreign
Mr chairman committee members
my name is Aubry Friedman I'm from
Bridgewater private citizen I speak in
support of this bill this is an
anti-snooping bill and I think it's a
good idea whenever there's a question
about privacy the burden of proof should
always be on government officials to
explain what they're going to do and
they can still get the warrant that just
puts an extra set of eyes on what you're
doing it doesn't stop them from doing
their job and by the way so it was
mentioned there will be a big delay if
somebody requests it well also the
person who's going to request the
warrant they're going to be
inconvenienced for a couple hours too so
I think if they're doing it uh there's a
you know there's a reason for it it's
going to be a big inconvenience for them
too so we should consider that also
um the current law
it invites selective enforcement and
possible corruption it's always good to
have that extra set of eyes uh for a
judge to uh just looking over your
shoulder doesn't stop anything anybody
from doing your job but actually it
protects you if you do anything
inappropriate you could say well the
judge okayed it so it's actually a
little bit protection for the officer if
you think about it too was already
mentioned Article 19 I'll just quote
here it codifies that a warrant Article
19 from part one of the New Hampshire
Constitution Bill of Rights warrant must
be issued to protect quote right to be
secure from all reasonable searches and
seizures of his person his houses his
papers and all his possessions and again
I say when it comes to law why is this
one different than all other Law
Officers we have to uh the same rules
should apply to all
I also like the wording they changed it
from reasonable and articulate
articulable suspicion to probable cause
uh again it's privacy protection for the
individual when there's any question
private privacy versus uh you know the
common good or the public I'm always
more in favor of privacy protection for
the individual
um
and that's it um any questions
oh and I have a
alternative okay if you have something
you'd like to share you can
um I I just have a quick question have
you have you considered
that there's no right per se to to fish
that's granted by by the state the state
controls the fishing it's license when
you enter the same as when you you buy a
concert ticket you enter into a contract
with the owner that says I I will go to
your concert but you can search my stuff
going in when you obtain a fishing
license do you not think that that might
also be a conditional waiver of some of
your rights in exchange for your ability
to fish
uh privacy rights have you specifically
given them up
that's my question do you I don't think
so I think privacy is is key and it's
clear here in the Constitution and I
think just in reasonableness
if somebody's going to search you a
government official who's got police
power uh that's not something you give
up automatically uh
it should be with you always as far as
I'm concerned okay representative Newell
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I think the way that I'm hearing it
from you is that this is a matter of
principle and and I'm wondering if you I
I you have
um explained that the potential for
abuse but I I just was wondering if you
have any examples of actual instances
where it has been abused no I do not I
agree it's it's a principle to me and
that that's why I'm here testifying for
principle privacy protection versus
police power I mean it's um any any
question on that I weigh more inside on
the size of privacy and that's why you
have to have the warrant so it's a
principal thing thank you
thank you for your testimony this
morning
[Music]
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify this morning my
name is Eric ORF I'm a wildlife
biologist and have been a wildlife
biologist here in New Hampshire for a
half century now my tact will be a
little different today I think the
colonel will be able to explain the
semantics and the uh in the particular
mechanics of this legislation but I'm
here this morning representing the New
Hampshire Audubon and like Mr Baker the
uh the New Hampshire wild Refrigeration
I first joined the Wally Federation as a
junior member in 1964. I've been on the
board for several decades and the vice
president for several years now the New
Hampshire Wally Federation is the voice
for New Hampshire Sports women and men
and has been so for nearly a hundred
years the New Hampshire Audubon have
been on their policy committee and I
submitted to the clerk some written
testimony earlier but uh back to the
Wildlife Federation if we cast our eyes
out the window right now it looks like
winter but you know bald eagles are
setting up their territory senior Barrel
just at New Hampshire Audubon tells me
last year there were 92 pairs of bald
eagles when I first became a biologist
there were zero
we have two dozen pairs of peregrine
falcons here in New Hampshire turkeys I
work for a fish and game as a wildlife
biologist for over three decades until I
retired in 07 and was recruited by the
national wildly Federation to do some
Consulting for them you know the Ranger
Rick folks so uh but what have I
witnessed over that last 50 years bald
eagle zero to Chris says likely 100
pairs this year peregrine falcons like
never before turkeys who hasn't seen a
turkey in this room this week There's 50
000 turkeys up from zero when I was
first there so we have a preponderance
of fish and wildlife in New Hampshire
and uh you know and and it's been a team
effort you know my 30 years at
fishingham worked very closely with the
law enforcement division it's a team
effort every tool makes a difference and
it has been productive we have more fish
and wildlife in this state than in a
couple hundred years it's been very
fruitful and and effective and is now
enjoyed by the majority of our citizens
and those to come that have yet to be
born I'm sure but we've all been in the
uh the grocery store aisle and you see
the young family ahead of us and the
child reaches out for the candy and the
mother says no well I just told you we
have more
deer up from forty thousand to a hundred
thousand Bears I was the bear biologist
when there was a thousand Bears now
there's over six thousand wow
it becomes a little more tempting to
take things when they're abundant
doesn't it so we need the regulations
and laws that have been very effective
for the last 50 years to pass this bill
would they go backwards we don't want to
go backwards we have momentum and I
think we should maintain that momentum I
would ask the committee members here to
vote this bill and expedient to
think of your testimony and the
you have to pardon me on this one
um David
anybody named David
Annie Davids
is this possibly your your card
Henry are you a doctor sir oh that could
I had difficulty writing reports As A
Firefighter too so
my name is David Poole and I represent
the New Hampshire guides Association
today we are here in opposition to this
bill and I and I think a couple of the
uh
points that I was going to make have
been well spoken to by some of the folks
in front of me what I will say is that I
um
the sponsor identified that there could
be some delay uh if you were in a remote
area I operated as a fishing guide in
Pittsburgh
operating primarily on three and a half
miles of river and there is a single
sometimes there's a single Co
conservation officer that covers all of
Pittsburgh and depending on the day
could be covering a lot more
so if an individual decided in that
three and a half miles there could be
50 or 60 or 70 conservatively Anglers
one person decides that they're going to
exercise their right because they need
to they've created they are in violation
or because
it's principle that they're going to ask
for a warrant should this bill be passed
that conservation officer for all
practical purposes is out of business
will never see any of the other 59 or
69 people that are on that piece of
water just that one little piece of
water
for the rest of the day it's at least
half an hour to go to Colebrook
get a warrant
get back
oh and by the way they'd have to secure
the the
person that and secure the evidence so
I'm not sure how that would work there's
a lot going on and in all that time
there's no education of Anglers that has
gone on one person spoke to the fact
that just a mere presence of a green
uniform
uh
how can we put that encourages good
behavior
and that's not happened they only got to
that one person and
their day is primarily over
um as a guide
a lot of damage could be done in a very
short period of time without enforcement
for fish and game I witness it day in
and day out so I would I would we
would encourage you to find this pill uh
well
to find the next beginning to legislate
please
that's it
chair calls Jim to Tony if I got that
right
Mr chairman house committee members I
want to thank you for the opportunity
for me to speak here today
my name is Jim tatone I'm from Seabrook
I've been fishing lobsters in the state
since 1965. I'm here today on behalf of
the 60 plus members of the Yankee
Fisherman's Cooperative in Seabrook
I'm not good at speaking off the cuff so
I hope you don't mind if I read my
statement here
bounded over 150 years ago the New
Hampshire Fish and Game department The
Roots conservation offices
serves as a gut as the Guardians of the
states Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources
the commercial and recreational
Fisheries industries of this state
consider the offices of the New
Hampshire Fish and Game department to be
a vital element in the enforcement of
laws and regulations which are critical
to assure the sustainability of our
natural resources our conservation
offices must continue to have the
ability to search without warrants any
commercial or recreational vessel
any premises where where aquatic species
are landed any containers or vehicles of
recreational Fishers
any other pertinent duties to assure
that their mission can be successfully
accomplished
we believe that the ability of
conservation officers to search and
seize without a warrant on land are at
Sea is an effective deterrent against
any real or potential violations of fish
and game laws and regulations
the New Hampshire lobster industry is a
dynamic economic driver for this state
it is unimaginable unimaginable that
conservation offices would be handcuffed
in performing their duties by having to
obtain a warrant to search or seize we
consider the fishing game to be our
partner in the effective management and
conservation of the state's valuable
Lobster resource
now down at our fish Co-op
we can have up to 20 boats a day Landing
and it shouldn't be a requirement for a
fish and game officer to come down on
the dock and get without a warrant to
board a vessel to sample their catch and
the same should apply to the premises
where all these lobsters are landed we
have about four to five thousand pounds
of lobsters a day landed in our tanks
and we sometimes have up to three to
four thousand pounds of ground fish a
day landed at our Co-op and
we shouldn't have to be have I think
Fish and Game offices tied to be able to
come into our premises aboard our
vessels to sample what catch we have and
I just hope that we can
and continue to have this kind of
coverage for my fishing game offices
that's all I have to say thank you and
I'm willing to take any questions if
there being none I appreciate testimony
uh thank you for uh the opportunity to
uh give testimony to this
particular bill
um I'm Ward Byrne I'm a uh commercial
officer fisherman out of Portsmouth New
Hampshire I'm the owner operator of the
fish and vessel sugar daddy
um when I first saw Eric's post on this
bill
I was kind of shocked that we would want
to jeopardize our working relationship
with fish and game and
that's how I see it these guys uh like
assault of the earth to work with on the
water they're great I can think of no
circumstances ever where I felt like my
constitutional rights were violated it
just doesn't happen
on a normal day say they come out they
see my vessel they drive up to us hey
guys how's it going
good they jump on
I show them my Lobster permit
um I show them my commercial salt water
license
and occasionally they'll pull up the
tank they'll take a look at a couple
lobsters and off they go that's pretty
much a routine stop for fish and game
there's no they're not down and below in
my builds digging for stuff that's not
how it works
um Mike said it best most of us are
friends with them
you know like we we have a great work
and relationship and this is
going to create a quagmire of
call it red tape whatever you will
um and I say that because it's
um
she had brought up earlier what it would
cost
well I had spoken to enforcement an
actual Warden that works on the water
this morning
and he explained to me how it would work
they would stop check us he'd have to
wait get a warrant and this warrant
wouldn't be an emergency
so it would be at the Leisure of a judge
to make sure he checked his emails
so that he could issue the warrant it
could take days it could take seven
hours maybe four hours I don't know but
it's going to cost me money
um we talk about the resource in
protecting the resource
the resource this is a well-managed
fishery it's the most sustainable
fishery on the East Coast out there to
um I have a son and a daughter they're
also involved in Fisheries you know I'm
not going to be fishing for the next 40
years but my there's a potential that my
my son and my daughter are and I think
it's Paramount that we do not handcuffed
our relationship with fish and game for
what could be perceived as violating My
Liberty I more look at it like
it's
I kinda
um when I signed my Lobster permit and
buy it there's a certain due diligence
in in a line for me
that I'm going to be work with these
people and not against them
so that's I guess pretty much what I
have thanks
any questions no thank you for your
testimony
that's the last one yeah okay
Jordan
chair uh calls
good morning I I too have some uh
paperwork I'd like to distribute for the
committee
so this bill has been before the house I
think we're up to seven times now if you
haven't ever heard me testify you will
never forget it because I'm very
passionate about it and I'm very
passionate about it because I agree with
almost every person who's been up here
and if you watch closely you'll see
representative Hull fall out of his
chair but I agree with him as well I
don't think there's anything on God's
Earth more precious to me than my rights
my civil rights and I lead my agency
with that in mind and I don't read about
it ladies and gentlemen I make my living
on it every day that's what I'm paid to
do is to to pay attention to people's
rights and I know chairman Roy did it
for years as a police officer he knows
exactly what I'm saying it is not
something to be taken lightly under any
circumstances or any conditions I do
disagree with with representative hole
and I'll give you a little bit of
History because I was I was the reason
this changed we never fishing game
officers for uh since the 30s have never
had add the ability or the powers or the
authority to stop a motor vehicle on the
highway now most of us never worried too
much about that until you came across
working a Night Hunter for instance you
were out at night working in a field
which encompasses a lot of time at night
you're coming home at two o'clock in the
morning and you come up behind a motor
vehicle that's all over the road
based on the same we all get and this is
important to remember all police in the
state of New Hampshire and I think we're
very lucky here all state all police in
the state of New Hampshire get equal
training I'm in the academy with
Troopers with sheriffs with local police
officers and I think that's the key to
the success that New Hampshire law
enforcement has had is that we all
receive the same training at the same
level that's very important to remember
so I know based on my training
experience that I'm following an
impaired driver
and so naturally I'm a police officer
with with emergency blue lights it's my
responsibility and duty to stop this
person before they run someone over on
the highway a relative of one of you
the problem with that is in those days
if you pulled over a drunk driver
you essentially have signed his ability
to get away with that charge because you
don't have the authority to do that so
I've got officers driving behind a drunk
driver
they are weighing in their mind should I
get this guy off the road because they
know that they should by law because
it's the right thing to do but they also
know if in fact they do that they're
going to lose that case in a courtroom
and it was done all the time the defense
attorney would get up and his first
argument would be who stopped did you
stop representative approved from
driving down the highway drunk yes sir I
did did you and what Authority did you
do that with well I didn't have the
authority and so that case would go out
the window
that's just one example there would be
speeding there would be Reckless
operation it would be all of those
things that involved the motor vehicle
stuff but we didn't have the powers
so I went to the Municipal Police
Association I talked to the New
Hampshire State Troopers Association and
we worked together back in 2014 to get
that Authority for that simple reason
I don't have game wardens and you're not
going to see you better not see game
wardens out on Interstate 93 in their
cruiser with a radar gun they've got way
too much to do that was not why we did
that we did it for emergency type
situations and only that when you saw
someone who was endangering the public
or endangering themselves and if you
didn't take immediate action that danger
could could multiply so in 2014 we asked
and came here to this body in the Senate
and asked for that Authority and
explained all of this and and that was
put into the law and representative Hull
quoted it
almost correctly
I'll read it to you and it's very
important the other thing I want to
explain to you in a courtroom if you
haven't ever been in a courtroom
prosecuted a case when you prosecute a
case based on the laws that you folks
write for us
you can win or lose a case based on one
word in a statute if a word says or
instead of and and you took a step that
didn't include that you're going to lose
your case I struggle with that with
young officers they don't understand
that they think it should be common
sense Common Sense doesn't exist in a
courtroom for many reasons they read a
statute literally the way it's written
that's why we're over here hammering all
the time to make sure that they're
written so that we can enforce it and
this is a good example of why that's
important
so I'll read it to you two and four this
was the new paragraph added in 2014 to
enforce all provisions of RSA title 21
which is relative to Motor Vehicle Laws
absent
any efficient any violation of suspected
violation of fish and game laws and this
is what's key ladies and gentlemen with
the same Authority and Powers as any
other certified law enforcement in the
state
the same Authority and Powers is any
other certified law enforcement officer
in the state that does not give me the
authority to pop a trunk on a car on 93
unless New Hampshire State Police can do
it it's the same authorities and Powers
you can't you can't do that kind of
stuff in America today thankfully you'd
be on the front page of every state
paper
so that problem that he brought up does
not exist because the it's very clear in
the law and we wrote it that way so that
it would be very clear in the law
because it was a debate back then about
us having more Powers than anyone else
and I hear that all the time it's a hoax
we're all bound by the same Constitution
we're all bound by the same Federal
Constitution thankfully we all have to
operate the same what differs with us
and what people struggle to understand
and we and as I said we've been here six
times with this HB 282 HB 1091 HB 1677
HB 1566 and today HB 4498 it's because
people don't understand it the good news
is the guys in force in this do
understand it and I tell you that
because I'd ask you today to reach back
in your recent memory and tell me when
the last time you saw a New Hampshire
Fish and Game officer on the news or in
any local papers violating someone's
rights or listen to the people that have
been up here behind me that we board
their boats on a regular basis that we
stop in the field when they're hunting
and fishing they're here telling you
they want that to continue those are the
very people that are subject to those
searches now I don't want to ignore what
the young man said from Bristol Bristol
or Bridgewater I'm with him on principle
I'm with him that those rights are very
important we don't have that Authority
you know when I get a young guy on and
we get him in a room those first two
weeks and we start telling them you know
we start talking about powers and
authorities and they get real excited
because they think they can just go and
and rip your backpack off and start
searching it they can do that once
they're going to get away with it once
and then they're going to get their case
handed to them and they're probably
going to be looking for work because you
can't do that thankfully we have the
same Authority what what I always try to
liken it to is think about what a police
officer does because everybody knows
that I was a police officer for years
unlike popular belief you do not need
probable cause to stop a car on a
highway television will tell you that
what was your probable cause for the
start that's a hoax you don't need it
you need articulable suspicion to stop
that person there's a big difference
between those two articable suspicion is
I think based on a certain set of facts
that this individual is doing something
wrong that's our tickable suspicion
probable cause is much higher than that
probable cause is I can prove that this
person is doing something wrong okay
so a police officer on the highway is
only required to have articulable
suspicion then he can pull you over he
has to be able to articulate later in a
courtroom why he did that he can't make
something up it's got to be he's got to
be speeding there's got to be a swerve
or a light out there's got to be
articulable suspicion once he stops you
he can ask for your license he can look
in the car and see if your child's in a
in a car seat he can look in and see if
you got your cell phone in your hand and
your texting he can if he smells alcohol
he can ask you to step from the vehicle
and he can perform a field sobriety test
those are all searches ladies and
gentlemen that's a search
those are searches we get to do the same
thing we get to do the very same thing
we're not in a car but I see you fishing
you're casting a line into the water I
might see you catch a fish you're
reeling it up is that an articulable
suspicion or a reason to check your
fishing license if you're required to
have it by law and you're fishing long
as I can demonstrate that you're fishing
I can go check your license while I'm
there we typically will ask you if you
caught any fish how's the fishing today
and people will say yeah I've caught two
our next standard answer to that our
question is can I see him can I see your
fish do you know 99.9 of the time people
will openly show you their fish but
let's say somebody doesn't let's say
they don't show you the fish no I don't
want to show you the fish I run into
representative Hull who knows what his
rights are and he says Nope Colonel
you're not looking in my backpack
my officers don't have the The Authority
at that point to rip his backpack off
and look in it they're gonna go get a
warrant for that okay whether they like
it or not that's how that's going to
work
and and I'm telling you that happens
because if it didn't happen think about
where we are in a close watch that's on
law enforcement today in this country
anyone violating those rights would be
discovered the courts would not tolerate
that not for a second thankfully this
law has been on the book since 1935 it
was created so essentially it's been in
law for 88 years and in 88 years I
couldn't sit here and accurately
um guesstimate at how many times that's
had judicial review a court trial but I
can bet it's in the hundreds of
thousands if not more defense attorneys
Prosecuting attorneys people a lot
smarter than me judges all reviewing
this and arguing whether it was
legitimate whether it was legal whether
it violated someone's rights and yet
here we are 88 years later it hasn't
changed it hasn't changed it's gone to
the Supreme Court three times New
Hampshire Supreme Court on three
occasions and I brought those the first
one was in 1973
no relation to a previous speaker who
was here with State V Marconi and this
involved a lobster fisherman Who
challenged the fact that we boarded a
boat and did a regulatory inspection of
his catch and our New Hampshire Supreme
Court quoted this I'll quote them
if I can see it
we do not read in our statutes any such
all-encompassing restraints on ordinary
Patrol and inspection of lobster
fishermen nor do we find the Fourth
Amendment your right to against illegal
searches to the United States
Constitution bars a reasonable
inspection of lobster boats operated
under the license from the state so they
viewed the very fact of of why this bill
was brought today and said it doesn't
violate anyone's rights they didn't stop
there that we brought another case in
2009 a gentleman by the name of Paul
Kimball who refused to let an officer
into a bob house on a public body of
water our Supreme Court once again
reviewed the law the 206-26 in in
particular and said further the Court
held that Hensel who was the officer at
the time had reasonable cause which is
the same as or similar articulable
suspicion to believe that the defendant
had illegal wildlife in the Fish House
he was justified under the law to search
the fish house and seize all the
evidence without the defendant's
permission without the need of a search
warrant
that was in 2009 and then finally in
2011 State beauchement involved a
baiting case and a quote from that
decision from our New Hampshire Supreme
Court permits conservation offices go on
any property outside of a building to
enforce Wildlife rules and regulations
but does not allow them to enter such
buildings without a warrant thankfully
here the defendant's porch was part of
the property outside of the house and
building officer Brown was therefore
with any statutory powers to go on the
defendant's porch and enforce all the
laws and regulations what's important
about that those are three times that
our that this law has gone to our
Supreme Court where we rely on them to
make these changes and I can assure you
if this law was defective it would have
been changed I've told my officers on
100 different occasions at the end of
legislative Seasons don't worry about a
bad law don't worry if you got a lot of
fellows at the guys and gals that you
don't think you can enforce because the
best way to change them and chairman Roy
will agree with this the best way to
change a bad law is go out and enforce
it
go out and enforce the law they gave you
because it's going to change if it's not
right and it isn't fitting it's going
the courts are going to do that for you
in 88 years they haven't done it on this
I think that's key and then I'm going to
leave you with this final thought I'm
always proud when I come over here and
hear our constituents come up and talk
about my officers and how they're how
they're treated by them because I and we
insist on that I don't it isn't a heavy
lift because they're good people they
are the best people they didn't get
stipends to stay employed unlike many
state employees did my guys did not get
that they were very angry about that and
I said to them you don't have to get
paid to do what you guys are doing
you're we don't have a shortage of
people over there I'm very proud to say
we have a good outfit it's a big family
is what it is and it's a small group
what I'm driving towards is there's a
list that comes out every year we used
to call it the Lorry list it's now
called the exculpatory evidence schedule
and it lists over 200 police officers
that have made mistakes in our state
working these mistakes range from lying
to crowd to crimes to violating
violating the rights of our citizens I
would encourage you to go look at that
list and you find me a New Hampshire
conservation officer on that list
because I'm here to tell you you won't
see it because it doesn't happen they
don't abuse these Powers if they did
they would be on that list and I'm very
proud of the fact that they're not I'm
sorry I rambled on but I'm very
passionate when someone says that we're
violating people's rights because we
don't do that I would not allow that
thank you for your testimony this
morning Karen oh I'm sorry represent we
have one question representative Newman
yeah I just have one question and it I'm
just trying to figure out how all this
works all the way to the end so you
can't you talked about
um
the uh the suspicion I've checked those
suspicious suspicion
and you went through and said some you
had circumstantial evidence there are a
couple of fish and then you want to look
in the backpack yes and the one percent
says no yep what happens what
potentially could happen or what usually
happens however you want to describe it
what would happen after that and of
course like so it would depend on the
situation but if he had articulable
suspicion to believe that fish were
illegally uh taken and and in that
backpack he would have the authority to
look in there if he was was if he was
guessing at that fact if he was just out
and and didn't see him catch fish he
came by at the end of that and and just
thought well he might have fish in there
I should ask him and look in there he
would not have the authority to tear his
backpack off and go through it he would
lose that in a quorum thank you yes sir
the other thing that's important to
remember is you you know this these
powers and Authority do not allow you to
circumvent
uh or to use these powers and authority
to go after a marijuana or or uh or a um
uh safe an illegal safe taken under
burglar you're only looking for wildlife
you can only you're only going to be be
able to justify your articulable
suspicion relating to Wildlife that's
what these powers do if you find
something else you need to stop and go
get a search warrant we just finished
we're working on a very big case that's
going to be that's going to hit the news
here soon that is going to shock some
people in the state where better than 30
animals were taken illegally it was a
whole ring that involved four different
states then the officers are wrapping it
up now we have done a total of I think
we're up to nine search warrants that we
write and I got to tell you that has
changed today we when I was in the field
I could write a warrant I knew my judges
they were friends of mine I go bang on
their door on a Sunday night go in and
it was relatively quick you don't do
that anymore this is all electronic now
and what you heard earlier is exactly
right you're going to be tied up I had
an officer do a war at noon submit it at
seven o'clock that night I called him to
see what the status was he hadn't gotten
a warrant back yet now I'm gonna have to
hold These Guys these Lobster fishermen
I'm going to tie them at a pier
for six hours while I search for a
warrant I I don't know that I'm man
enough to do it to Mr Flanagan to be
honest with you quite frankly can you
think about that though you're going to
cost these guys their living and and and
I'll tell you how that's going to work
I'm not going to do that I'm not going
to cost these guys their boat or their
living so they're going to go unchecked
and if they go unchecked our resources
are going to pay that price everybody's
going to lose from that because I'm not
going to allow that to happen you can't
allow that to happen so it's important
that these and and these regulatory
Powers exist in many places border
searches Department of Motor Vehicle
truck guys can go on and check logs it's
not just us it's not just us
if you could the same powers and
authorities that you have are no
different than the powers and
authorities than the wildlife police in
Maine Massachusetts Vermont you don't
have some this is across the state and I
also have a California the one I'm the
the most amazing and I hope I don't
offend anyone but I think the state of
California is probably the most liberal
state in the country the state of
California took this it's it was RSA
2012 in the state of California on a
lobster fisherman guys they they took
this case up and they made the exact
same decision in California I still
can't get over the fact if this exists
across the country there's only one
state I know of uh chairman Roy that
doesn't allow this and it's uh North
Carolina I believe every other state has
some version of this yes and and when
you speak to Authority a State Trooper
can stop a vehicle for speeding they can
stop a drunk they can check a fishing
license they can make a night hunting
case if they so desire they can enforce
criminal law a fish and game officer can
stop at DWI we can enforce a burglary if
we want to we can do fish and game law a
county sheriff has we all have the same
Powers everybody goes to the same
Academy we get the same training same
certification we all kind of the only
difference is Troopers can't go into a
town and I can't even quote it
accurately under assert over a certain
population without permission I think is
the only thing so other than that we're
all on this it's a wives tale that we
have secret powers you know I'd like to
say we do but we don't we don't we're
the same as everybody else
with regard to California I think that
nothing is more bipartisan than Wildlife
right
um there'd be no further questions I
I I'm just wondering what happens on the
weekend in terms of you getting warrants
so it makes it more difficult because
you've got to locate you call a I
believe we call a central number now
on-call judge they put a judge on call
and you have to wait for that and so
that does involve if I had someone if my
officers had someone that they felt uh
they had a home that they thought a deer
was brought into and they're pretty sure
the deer was in there they're going to
do a warrant we would sit on that home
until that judge signed a warrant you
can't leave because they're going to get
rid of that evidence so you have to sit
on it and I'd also ask you to bear in
mind that we've got 35 field officers in
the entire state the city of Concord has
50 police officers covering the city
Concord I'm covering from Pittsburgh
Massachusetts from Vermont to Maine with
35. so that would put a huge burden on
there are going to be other big balls
dropped basically if we have to do that
certainly thank you thank you
thank you thank you sir
sorry for the length of time
quite all right anyone else is there
anyone else who hasn't testified on this
bill that wishes to testify
there being none I hereby closest public
hearing
at this time I'm open to public hearing
on hb504 and I recognize Prime sponsor
thank you chairman Roy I did send my
card
just hold on for a second on your
okay
good okay thank you chairman Roy and
members of the committee my name is Mary
Jane walner and I'm a state
representative from right here in
Concord you're almost sitting in my ward
um
so House Bill 504 was the request of Me
by the uh the chair of the parole board
requested this piece of legislation and
what the bill would do would allow the
chair of the board to appoint previous
board members to sit on the board as
needed
and what he finds is sometimes he has a
situation where he can't
um all he can't um find three parole
board members that are available for
hearings and this would allow him to use
one of the previous board members and
the bill would appropriate
there would be a stipend of three
hundred dollars a day and he's asked for
five days a year that he would be able
to have a previous board member sit in
when he didn't have enough enough parole
board members present the bill also
raises the stipends to parole board
members from twenty thousand a year to
thirty thousand a year and raises the
vice chair's reimbursement from twenty
thousand to forty thousand the chair is
a full-time unclassified state employee
the bill we provide fifty one thousand
five hundred dollars a year to cover the
cost of the new parole board members
stipends
and uh last year the parole board dealt
with over a thousand cases
their work is complicated
complex and very important to our state
I urge you to vote this bill out ought
to pass send it on to the finance
committee so the finance committee can
look at the financial aspects of the
bill chair Roger Phillips is here and
he'll go into detail about the work of
the board and this piece of legislation
and how important it is to them and I
thank you and I'm open to questions but
I think Mr Phillips would certainly be
able to answer most things better than I
can
thank you
great
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Roger Phillips
and I'm chairman of the adult parole
board and with me today uh
is Jay Mackey who's director of
I wanted to to thank both representative
walner and representative scitec for
sponsoring this bill uh I understand
representative sitec is busy with some
some matters on on the county level
today uh
and but I I do appreciate that certainly
appreciate the sponsorship I thought I'd
Begin by just giving a brief overview of
the parole board and its functions and
and why we're asking for the
the changes in this bill
excuse me the I went to the doctor last
Friday and they discovered I have
um an allergy during the winter time
which is a little bit unusual uh after
being 43 years in one house by moving
into another we discover there are
certain ambiggins of it so it it has
affected my voice and sometimes I have
to clear my throat a bit but please bear
with me
um the
the parole board is a five-member board
of which I am
um one I was trying to I was appointed
chairperson
approximately nine months ago although
I've been on the board since 2019.
um the
um
as representative Wald indicated I am a
full-time member an unclassified
employee of of the state but the board
members are part-time
um
the five-member board holds pairings for
both parole and for revocations and and
other matters too but we hold hearings
on Tuesdays and Thursdays of most every
week Tuesdays are Pearl revocation days
and and Thursdays are Pearl days
um the
um
the statute provides that we should have
36 hearings a year for each matter but
in fact uh we have more than that and uh
and I've attached to that are passed out
the what the number of hearings have
been usually we're we're into
the the 40s 45 hearings in each matter
um
the
makeup of the board
by Statute requires two attorneys the
reason for that is that on revocation
days there should be an attorney present
because of evidentiary issues or other
matters that could arise that where
legal expert
expertise would be required
um but there are also other members of
the board by the statute who one from
law enforcement or correction experience
so
uh one uh
who who's familiar with the criminology
uh
uh either through or or teaches the same
in post-secondary
education or and finally a third member
would be at large uh without any
specific designation I think
we're very pleased to have for
representing corrections as someone who
was a captain of of the corrections
officer in San Quentin who has a vast
amount of experience and moved to New
Hampshire and is a valuable member of
the board
we also have a former police officer who
teaches on the post-secondary education
level as a member
and we're also fortunate especially when
Medical Bureau matters come around
because we have a retired surgeon who is
also willing to sit as the at-large
member
um
the
the bill
um
during the covert times we discovered as
we were trying to schedule hearings
there were sometimes difficulty
of finding
um three members on any given day to sit
because of either sickness or
um or appointments or or for a conflict
of interest or for some reason
so just so the same way that courts
sometimes can call on retired judges I I
thought it might be a good idea that I
mean last year we had to cancel two
hearings because we we couldn't put the
panel together
and and I thought well we ought to have
some sort of safety valve here so that
we could call on those who had served in
to sit again and that's why we
propose that now it would take some
doing because now we're you know years
ago all parole packages were were in
paper and delivered in cardboard boxes
and we'd have to go through stacks of
paperwork now fortunately in the digital
age we all have an issue laptop
computers and we can access everything
in that way
um so it would take number one we have
to find out who'd be willing to serve
and there'd be some training involved
and then have to go through I.T and get
the appropriate
training for a person so they could look
up what what would
doing for a hearing of either revocation
or
um
that's it
in summary of concerning uh
that part and the
representative walner indicated that you
know we wouldn't think would happen very
often but it's only only a fifteen
hundred dollar appropriation we would
think
the
the next section is the
um
a bit different and that is we're asking
for increased compensation
and I wanted to go
over the fact that at least in my
opinion the parole board has a
significant role to play in public
safety
um
we'd know what board members must be
competent they must be well prepared
they must be dedicated and willing to
thoroughly review parole packets uh in
criminal records
in a parole matter there are at least 23
different subject areas that when
board members go through in determining
whether or not someone should be
entitled to parole
and preparation for parole hearings
takes a considerable amount of time
um I mean
I think on average it somewhere between
10 and 13 hours to go through the parole
packets and and to be prepared uh I I
might even take longer than that
sometimes I sat in on on a Friday night
into spending an hour organizing but I
spent a good part of Saturday and
sometimes a little bit of Sunday and
then again on Monday to get things ready
for either the Tuesday or the upcoming
Thursday hearings
um
oh the
and the other thing that I I want to uh
get across is when
the probability that you should be nine
members was reduced to five the initial
proposal was that each board member
would be paid thirty thousand and during
the legislative process that was reduced
to 20. I think that thirty thousand
dollar amount that was initially uh
suggested that was by at that time uh
chairperson Jennifer Sergeant but she
did some research on what Wards were
paid in other other states
um and and there are a lot of full-time
boards even the states a little bit
larger than New Hampshire where every
board member was paid a hundred thousand
dollars
that we know that in New Hampshire we we
do a lot because we do things from for
public service members of this
legislature are certainly well aware
that it's not compensation whereby
you're willing to sit and represent the
people of New Hampshire
um you know I was born and raised in New
Hampshire I'm well aware of what the
court does and my father both Winfield
Jade Phillips who who was State
Treasurer and Bank commissioner and then
served as a member of the House of
Representatives and I know how how hard
and difficult it is and it's an enormous
amount of work
but when we're dealing with a state
agency I think it's very important that
we attract those who are very competent
and willing to serve it's a hard job
it's not easy and
um
uh I just want to give one example
we had an individual with a vast amount
of law enforcement experience he was a
member of a metropolitan police force
outside the state of New Hampshire
you're done with the federal government
was a federal law enforcement agency and
he he became a member
and
all of a sudden he was hearing all of
these things and hearing input from
victims and although he was well aware
of what you know the the arrest process
and convicting someone but to hear the
effect on people
was such that he couldn't sleep at night
and it's not easy putting up with some
the the whether it's child abuse or you
know some horrific or terrible brutal uh
crimes whether it be
assault or something was done recklessly
but the
that it I think it takes a unique
individual to sit there
um and be fair and impartial
and also be able to sleep at night
um it's one of those things that we we
ought to consider so the reason you know
we've I've had experience over the last
you know since I've been on the board
where someone has resigned and it's been
very difficult to find a replacement
and that's why I'm urging the committee
to to accept the recommendation that
there be increased compensation for the
board member and then the final part of
this is we're also asking for
um
not just thirty thousand for a member
but for the vice chair to receive extra
compensation of ten thousand dollars a
year both the chair
and vice chair are the only ones that
sign warrants now in our Electronics now
under
the statue every board member has
Authority but there's a certain process
we have to go through so that we make
sure that we review the the warrants and
once their sign that they're ended in
the system electronically and in the
right places and the right people to
notify and to to prevent errors it's
good that two people do that but the
vice chair also gets involved in
other things so certainly for sharing
hearings when I can't or or for the
Motions that have files sometimes the
PPO needs to probation parole officer
wants to withdraw a warrant for a reason
or there might be changes in control
conditions and they're seeking
permission and there are lots of of time
spent by the Vice chair in doing uh
administrative duties that do not have
to be performed by the other members of
the board so that's why we're we're
asking for this change in the the
statute
um we
we heard in individual cases I think
last year more than uh 1400 cases and
they're out of both
parole and for revocation uh it it takes
a lot of effort and dedication on the
proud of board members to do their
duties
and with we would like to see this bill
passed
um we know that over the years there has
been a decrease in the prison population
uh I mean 10 12 years ago was probably
up to three thousand if not it seems to
be holding steady now at about 2 000.
and I also attached to my presentation
the fact that new persons coming in uh
that amount is slowly going up I can't
predict the future I know that when the
governor presented the when we had to
talk about presenting our budget and he
spoke and said the population of New
Hampshire is increasing uh and I think
that's true uh I wish that the increase
would only be of law-abiding citizens
but that may not be the case so I think
we have to be prepared uh to handle
whatever workload may be presented and
later on today there's a another bill
that will also be present to talk about
because if that were were passed that'd
be even more work for the pro board to
do
um but in the
um that's the extent of my presentation
for today but would be happy to answer
any questions that anyone has
or if I can't answer I say Mackie my
thank you
um I have a question regarding the two
days that were canceled so how many
cases did you were you unable to hear
that day and how long did it take you to
get them back in the queue in other
words I'm interested in the what what
that delay caused the people who were
trying to get a parole hearing
I I think Jay Mackey director so she had
to do that scheduling yeah I I had to
take over scheduling when we had a
retirement in the office
um so when we had the vacancy we had to
cancel those two hearings
um it was we ended up having to move
people that were in the next hearing
because people are heard we try to hear
them within 60 days of their minimum
parole date so they can hopefully get
out by their minimum approval date and
so we we had to take people from the
next parole hearing schedule move them
to another one to start fitting some of
these people on we started putting them
on revocation hearing schedules as well
um wherever we could find room over I
would say the next month we got to hear
all of them so they were still heard
within their minimum before the minimum
parole date and still had the
opportunity to hopefully if they were
approved and get a housing plan
approved by their minimum they could be
released on their minimum
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I I was listening when you were
talking about the preparation right um
and and being uh uh bringing a quality
um individual to that situation and so
my question is when there are situations
where someone is ill or something like
that there's not a lot of time to
prepare so is would would you say that
it's possible for someone to substitute
in that situation and still bring
um and still be properly prepared uh so
that they are doing their you know that
fulfilling their role to the to the best
that they can would would not scheduling
this is where we we try to schedule in
advance
so that might look back for instance in
late November we did January February
March and I'm working on April May and
June
but in those days people the board
members submitted me in advance states
that they're not going to be available
so I will know in advance if there
aren't certain members that you know if
I can't put together a panel that it's
going to be obvious right away so this
isn't something where where someone uh
is
suddenly ill the day of the hearing and
can't make it we're not going to do that
okay thank you thank you but there's a
preparation really requires much more
thank you oh is that it okay thank you
for your testimony all right thank you
very much I appreciate it is there
anyone else which can testify this bill
who has not
I mean none I close the public hearing
and I opened a public hearing no no oh
do I why are we caught up
foreign
okay
this time I'm going to open a public
hearing on House Bill 545 and recognize
the sponsor to introduce his bill
thank you Mr chair Dan Hines a
representing town of Bedford and I'm
putting this bill to amend the victims
Bill of Rights and it does a few
different things
um so broadly um the first thing it do
does is would expand the victim Bill
rights to misdemeanor cases uh so
presently only applies in felony cases I
think it's a good thing to apply it to
misdemeanor cases
um the next thing it would do is it
would allow victims
um to have a no contact order moved
against them so typically
um when someone is arrested mainly for
domestic violence cases but it does
apply to other cases there is a no
contact order issued by the Bell
commissioner and what happens is people
usually don't get an arraignment for a
while on some courts it can even be a
month out others it's at least a few
weeks but what happens often is that the
victim doesn't want there to be a no
contact order
um so I mean one example is if
um a mother is accused of some form of
domestic violence symbol assault
something like that um against the
father typically the battle commissioner
would say well you can't go to the home
you can't have contact with the person
even through phone or anything like that
so that's typically what I would see in
most cases and so often that is very
destructive to families
um oftentimes the person who has the
restraining order put against them they
don't want it they want that person to
be able to come home they want to
continue maintaining their house and
especially when there's children
involved oftentimes it does require both
parents to be involved with that child
particularly you know if someone's in
school and someone's typically there for
the child afterwards so it can be very
disruptive just to have these male
conditions in place so what this would
do would allow the victim to say I don't
want that Belk Edition in place or no
contact or part of the vacuum condition
um they could even
they wouldn't have to remove it all
together if they wanted they could say
well I just want to be able to talk to
person over the phone I want to text
them I want to email them or I want to
have contacted with them as long as the
third person's there so that would also
be
um they're right to do so and presently
if the victim wants to bail condition
um no contact order removed they have to
go and find a judge and the judge has to
approve it uh sometimes judges do
sometimes they don't sometimes it
depends on the process computer's input
but either way it does take a while to
actually get to court to have these
things happen so this would just allow
the victim to have a right to have that
no contact order removed the second
thing or one other thing you would do is
allow what's called an accordion
satisfaction so Massachusetts has this
basically an accordion satisfaction is a
victim would come to some agreement
saying okay I'm essentially made whole
as a result of what you've done and I
want the charge dismissed so things
where it can typically arise is I think
shoplifting is a good case for it where
or I mean at the end of the day the shop
owner typically wants their money back
is a form of restitution they might be
fine with that
um it could arise in destruction of
property cases
um it also could rise in simple assault
cases and it's not necessarily limited
to money so it could include having the
essentially defendant
um commit or uh commit
um have to complete counseling we could
involve other treatment it could involve
different things and
um so it's not limited just to money and
there is a typo on my bill on that line
for the it's line 11. I did ask OLS to
draft an amendment
um but it presently reads to have a
charge against them dismissed that's
supposed to read a charge against the
defendant dismissed so I do have a
proposed amendment for that just to fix
that typo
um another thing that I think is less
common is to have a victim have a right
to withdraw withdraw restitution after
the fact so
um the reason I put this in is I saw a
case who's in a different state
um where essentially someone had
restitution amounts it was a lot
um and it was really preventing the
person sorry getting back on track and
the person
um the victim just lined it to go away
so I don't think this would be used a
lot but I think um restitution since it
is supposed to make someone whole that
they should be the one deciding whether
they actually want to terminate it so I
don't think it'll happen a lot but I
think it's a good option to give people
and then finally this just makes it
clear that um departments shall provide
a copy of this victim's Bill of Rights
to victim in cases
thank you
um I have a question
do you have any concerns about
um
victims being pressured into dropping
charges
um because of a thing like this where
um they don't necessarily have access to
to someone to advocate for them and if
if the offender is
putting pressure on them hey just drop
these charges everything will be fine
that type of thing yeah so I think
victims would have access to I mean I I
don't know if it's all police
departments but I think a lot of them do
have victim witness Advocates so there
are someone that they can talk to in
that regard
um
there's I guess there's separate crimes
I'd have to look at the exact language
um I I think the simple example I can
think of off the top of my head is if I
threaten someone don't go to court or
whatever
um so in regards to coercion I would
have to look at that specific language
um
so yes I I don't want people to be
allowed to course people so I would
support an amendment that I guess makes
it
not coercive I'm not sure the best
language that would be used for that but
I would support
um that type of concern to be addressed
um thank you Mr chair actually that was
the question I was going to ask
um but I have seen this situation and if
this is also in a different state
um where it was something that was
prolonged it was mandated by the state
and that it was prolonged and and there
were situations that were run into
because of that or restraining order
um but I haven't seen that in New
Hampshire and it seems to me that there
is a recourse there is a way to go
through a judge and do that it just
takes a you know takes a little bit of
time first of all uh so my first
question is do you know about how long
that takes and
um I'm just trying to determine if
that's actually cumbersome or if it
could be protective in the situation
where someone would be coerced or
something yep so in my experience the
first chance they're gonna get in front
of the judge is the arraignment um so
often courts don't even have a file
before then
um so I've tried to file basically
emergency motions to get it amended and
if there's good reason courts tend to
hear them sooner but even in the recent
case I'm thinking that I mean it was it
was probably like a week still um
sometimes you can get a judge to do it
super fast
um but I think the typical time that
would be dressed is at the arraignment
and that can range anywhere from I mean
I guess the next day if someone's held
or typically in my experience it's
probably going to be roughly around a
month so probably two to six weeks is
representative Selleck thank you Mr
chair very quick question
um your Bill calls itself the amending
the victim's Bill of Rights and I just
want to clarify by the victim you mean
the person who's been accused of
uh because at one point you talk a bit
victim in another defendant so I'm just
trying to figure out
whose rights these are yep so I'm not
changing definition of victim so the
victim is not the accused the victim is
what we would consider a victim so
um in a theft case the person whose
money was stolen in a assault case the
person who is battered um so I'm not
actually changing the definition of
victim
um where it might have been confusing is
that line 11 where I did have a typo so
that's pretty much where it would and
it's not adding any rights to defendants
um so it I I hope that answers your
question
the chair recognizes uh
I wasn't sure if it was supposed to be
red or white
red thank you good afternoon uh chairman
members of the committee my name is
Stephen Andrews I'm a prosecutor at the
Merrimack County Attorney's Office I've
been a prosecutor for a little over 20
years
I oppose this bill and asked to be found
in expedient to legislate
um
the the first thing to me is part two
article 88 of the New Hampshire
Constitution requires all indictments
and complaints in New Hampshire to
conclude with the language against the
peace and dignity of this state
and I think those are More Than Just
Words it's a recognition that crime is
committed against Society
there may be individual victims
but crime in New Hampshire is against
the peace and dignity of the state
I emailed the committee yesterday the
National District Attorneys Association
best practices guide for domestic
violence prosecution
and I handed out a letter from attorney
Halverson the Merrimack County attorney
who included the Attorney General's
model protocols for domestic violence
prosecution
and the reason I did that is because
domestic violence is a fairly fairly
complex subject and it's unlike many
other crimes
um
when you look at the ndaa best practices
guide it indicates that 80 percent of
victims recant
so 80 percent of domestic violence
victims
um don't want to cooperate with
prosecution
if victims had the ability to Simply
drop charges you'd end up in a scenario
where 80 percent of domestic violence
cases in New Hampshire would be
dismissed at the victim's request
uh
obviously the state has interests in
pursuing domestic violence that may
differ from the victim's interests
I I heard the sponsor indicate
something about shoplifting that
essentially an accordion satisfaction
with shoplifting where if the merchant
feels whole they don't have to go
forward with the case I would note that
in New Hampshire there's RSA 544c1 which
is essentially already allows merchants
in shoplifting cases to seek a civil
forfeiture of 400 dollars instead of
pursuing a criminal prosecution against
an individual
so to the extent there's an accordion
satisfaction with reference to theft
that that essentially already exists in
New Hampshire
I think that this bill
unfortunately sets the stage for victim
in intimidation for witness intimidation
because certainly if victims had the
right to to drop charges people that
were charged would perhaps want victims
to drop those charges and that doesn't
just relate to domestic violence that
would relate to gangs or any Community
any Community crime
attorney Halverson had reached out to
the other County attorneys regarding
this bill and I can indicate that in
addition to Merrimack County attorney
Halverson opposing it Cheshire county
attorney Chris McLaughlin opposes it
Rockingham County attorney Patricia
Conway opposes it Carroll County
attorney Michaela Andrews opposes it
co-as County Attorney John McCormick
opposes it Belknap County attorney
Andrew Livernois opposes it in Grafton
County attorney Marshall Hornick opposes
it uh I hadn't heard from anybody
involved in the law enforcement or
prosecution side of things that they
supported this bill and I would ask that
you find it inexpedient to legislate as
representative new
thank you Mr chairman could you
I know that there are uh domestic
violence is highly correlated with a
variety of other
um violent crimes
um can you speak to that at all I
considering the the crime against
Society aspect
I think that I don't have any statistics
of of what domestic violence is
correlated with
I went to a workshop several years ago
where a police officer was talking about
domestic violence and he said what
essentially this is is murder
intervention
and that really struck me that
this is a crime that can essentially
lead to this person being killed
okay
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee is this on you said red is the
magic color okay great thank you my name
is Lynn shellette I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence we
are the umbrella Organization for 12
community-based crisis centers
throughout New Hampshire that provide
free and confidential services to
approximately fifteen thousand victims
of crime every year victims of sexual
assault domestic violence stalking and
human trafficking I too am here to
provide testimony in opposition to House
Bill 545 which provides harmful changes
to New Hampshire's crime victim Bill of
Rights
on its face the bill appears to
strengthen the victim Bill of Rights but
in fact it does the exact opposite and
truly it takes us back decades the
criminal legal system is one that is
foreign and often intimidating to
victims
historically victims of crime especially
victims of domestic violence and sexual
assault were not treated well within
this system the courtroom was often
another place where a victim was
silenced and an offender was able to
continue to victimize the person that
they had already hurt
as a result of this pattern every state
in the country has a crime victim Bill
of Rights it may be embedded in their
statute it may be embedded in their
constitution and in some states it's in
both places
but the intent of these laws is the same
throughout the country the intent is to
ensure that victims have meaningful
participation in the process what that
means is that victims are treated with
dignity and respect that they have
notice of hearings and they are heard in
a meaningful way
this bill under the guise of
strengthening victims rights does just
the opposite in fact it moves several
functions of the state as you've already
heard from some witnesses back onto the
shoulder of victims and in so doing it
opens the door for offenders to engage
in further intimidation coercion and
harassment
as you heard earlier victims should
never bear the responsibility for the
crimes committed against them nor is it
the victim's job to hold offenders
accountable that is the job of our
communities and our states
therefore we oppose victims being able
to remove bail conditions or to modify
restitution that is the job of attorneys
and the court and as to the accord and
satisfaction piece that has been written
into this bill and it was referenced by
the sponsor if you look at the
Massachusetts language sexual assault
and domestic violence are explicitly
carved out from that option and as you
heard from attorney Andres that's
addressed elsewhere in New Hampshire law
if these functions are moved into the
hands of victims without the court
playing a role offenders are being given
a free pass to harass victims into
relinquishing remedies that have already
been ordered to protect them
victims who fear the public exposure of
a courtroom will be even less likely to
seek Justice
so in conclusion this bill would reverse
the progress we've made over decades
across the country to ensure that
victims are afforded the protection and
the participation that they deserve in a
criminal prosecution and if passed this
legislation would create an incentive
for abusers to further harm the people
they have already injured I encourage
you to vote itl and I'm happy to take
questions
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee good afternoon for the
record my name is David Goldstein I'm
the police chief in the city of Franklin
and I'm also the legislative chair for
the New Hampshire Association of chiefs
of police
and I'm here to represent that
organization and we oppose
uh this bill house bill 545.
by way of introduction for the record
I've been a police officer now for over
43 years
uh 23 of those years were with the New
Hampshire State Police
and 13 of those 23 years were with a
major crime unit
career-wise I've investigated over 100
homicides
of those 100 plus homicides more than 50
percent were domestic violence related
I'm the guy that gets to come here and
tell you the war stories about what this
does
early in my career
as a dairy police officer
I feel that a call from a victim of
domestic violence and I when I say
victim I mean victim this woman had been
beaten to within an inch of her life by
her living boyfriend
she'd been thrown down the stairs she'd
been beaten with a suitcase and anything
else that he could find
certainly I took the report investigated
it applied for Warren affidavit and
complained although it was a felony at
the time and arrested the gentleman
30 days to the day later she came into
the PD and recanted her statement
at that particular point in time being a
very young officer
I asked her if she really meant what she
was saying she said oh yeah yeah it was
just an accident no problem she said
fine and I arrested her for misdemeanor
unsworn falsification
I'm still paying Penance for that
decision 40 plus years later
that was wrong on my part
and there's no doubt in my mind that her
boyfriend her living boyfriend had
convinced her
to recance your statement I've seen many
we agree however with one thing in the
bill as presented but we certainly
oppose a bill as written and that's the
expansion of the class of victims that
you'll find in the first paragraph
but the rest of the bill raises many
questions
and I'm going to defer it to my
colleague and prosecutor Attorney Muller
to address some of those
as I've so often heard in these
committees as well as others over 14
years of serving in this particular
position this bill is not ready for
prime time not the way it's written
with that I thank you very much and I'll
defer to attorney Mueller
my name is Andrea Mueller I'm a
prosecutor for the Frank for Franklin
um I've been with the Franklin Police
Department for almost two years prior to
that I was with Manchester for
um just about nine years I did work in
the domestic violence unit in Manchester
and
um I do oppose the bill for a variety of
reasons many of which have been stated
by attorney Enders and Miss Chalet but I
would just like to address a few things
so the victim having the right to remove
the no contact order while the case is
pending that opens up the door to
witness tampering very often I have seen
in in practice when a judge after a
hearing removes the no contact order and
the parties are together soon after
either we lose the State loses contact
with the victim the victim no longer
wants to show up or he or she changes
his or her story
or minimizes it or recants and that and
that is a problem the state is also
concerned when the parties have contact
UM
that the cycle of violence
um that occurs with these domestic
violence cases is still ongoing so you
have a pending
case and
you have
a defendant who doesn't want obviously
doesn't want to get convicted he's
having contact with the victim this does
put the victim in in danger
um in terms of the Mr the victim having
a right in misdemeanor cases to to drop
the charges I see a few problems with
this
as attorney unders stated this is the
state versus the defendant it is the
state's case the prosecutor is the one
who is making the decisions in the case
yes the victim does have input and needs
to be consulted per the victim's Bill of
Rights but it is ultimately up to the
prosecutor about what the direction the
case is going to go in I'm also
concerned that if the victim has the
right to drop charges such as in
domestic violence cases if I or other
prosecutors have a case where we can
prove our case without the victim the
state should be able to the state does
have a greater interest in protecting
Society at large so someone who is
violent someone who is assaultive and is
threatening people while
those the victim and the defendant May
ultimately go their separate ways there
is still that interest of protecting all
of society from the defendant's
behaviors and I can say as a domestic
violence prosecutor I have seen
defendants come in with victim a and
then two years later they're back in
court with with victim B so this doesn't
stop after
one case
ends
um
I'm also concerned about
what this would do to the Court's
authority to issue orders for example if
someone is charged with violating a
protective order and the victim decides
I'm not going to go forward with these
charges then
essentially what is the point of having
the court issue orders if it's the
victim's call that they can then just
drop the charges
um and I I believe everything has has uh
already been covered that I had wanted
to say thank you
we'll certainly take any questions thank
you um I I have a question so under
current law the current situation if a
victim wanted to do any of these things
uh they're free to do that right now to
ask the judge to do these things I mean
it's not like they can't correct
my experience what happens is if should
the victim
file motion with the court usually
that's kicked back from the court
stating that they are not a party to the
case and it has to come from one of the
attorneys usually defense counsel will
file a motion to get those bail
conditions amended and the court will
schedule a hearing in my experience
those hearings have been scheduled
fairly frequently such as if someone
were to file a motion to amend bail
conditions today Friday January 27th it
would most likely get heard and put on
the Court's docket as an add-in sometime
next week
and I I guess I'm trying to get at is
they do have a voice in an input in the
case if they if they decide you know I
just don't want to pursue this anymore
their voice is heard yes we will
um consult with them and
um
they are notified of any potential plea
bargain
that we would offer representative
Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman I just would like
to clarify something that you said yes
um
you're you're when you're referencing
when you're referencing the state versus
this person and keeping the state and
Society safe as a whole essentially the
victim is the state's witness yes to
this crime correct here
uh chair recognizes Attorney Richard
head
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch I won't repeat
what you've already heard we agree and
adopt the the information that you've
already received without repeating it
the bill
um just very quickly in in on the page
one starting in line nine it says a
victim has the right to remove a
non-contact order between them and the
accused as a bail condition there's no
judicial oversight there's no provision
in which the court even knows about this
occurring if you have any subsequent
enforcement in that bail order
this is an undocumented change to the
bail order you have it anytime there is
a subsequent uh attempt to enforce you
have a significant risk of the potential
for the power and control that may
already exist to be exercised against a
victim in order to avoid some subsequent
enforcement of uh of a court order and
these are again all happening without
any oversight within without involvement
of the court or documentation through
the court they should be done in the
process that is already allowed for
which is through the parties to either
prosecutor or uh or a defendant and
again the next sentence a victim has a
right to a misdemeanor case to have a
charge against them dismissed I think
that means against the defendant
dismissed not against the victim uh due
to a court and satisfaction we agree
with the comments you've already heard
um in in essence what is happening here
is a disrespect of the court system a
disrespective court orders and
disrespect for the order of law on and
allows a defendant who already has power
and control over over a victim to
further exercise that without any
judicial oversight without any
involvement of the prosecutor we
strongly object and with that I'll
conclude my comments and be happy to
the chair recognizes attorney Jeff
stralzin please correct me
not an easy one
good afternoon my name is Jeff stralzen
I'm an associate attorney general at the
New Hampshire Attorney General's office
for RVC the criminal Bureau and
prosecutor almost 30 years in the last
22 plus Prosecuting murder cases at the
New Hampshire Attorney General's office
where I can answer one of the questions
that was asked about a correlation
between DV and other crimes have you
heard from the chief our numbers go back
a little over 40 years and I believe
it's around 45 to 50 percent of all of
our murder cases our domestic violence
related
some years it's a lot more some years
it's less but that historical average is
around 45 to 50 percent so it's
significant and that's and that's why
New Hampshire laws have a lot of
different Provisions that apply to
domestic violence and it's why we oppose
victims are emotionally involved in
their cases and as you heard sometimes
their allegiances can change it's always
good to have an objective person making
decisions about not only their safety
but their family's safety including
their children and that's why we oppose
this idea that a victim would be able to
unilaterally remove this no contact
provision that provision was put in
place after the court heard from both
lawyers and heard all the information
and made an informed decision
um you know we've I think we've all
heard the expression that if somebody
who represents himself has a full for a
lawyer the point is that sometimes it's
important to be objective and so here
the objectivity is guaranteed by the
fact that you have the court you have
prosecutors and you have defense
attorneys and so we believe we shouldn't
upend that system by allowing people who
have not only allegiances to different
people but can be pressured by different
people to make decisions that not only
impact their safety but their family's
safety so we're opposed to that portion
of a belt
we also oppose the piece called
according satisfaction
and that provision is Limitless and what
it means is essentially any defendant
who has enough money can make an offer
to the victim in their case to
essentially pay them off so the charges
go away so you're going to create this
system where the state is removed from
ensuring Justice and instead people who
either have the money or can get the
money can go to their victim and make
them an offer and then the charges have
to go away that's not what our system is
about I think the goal is Justice for
All and of course things aren't always
even in society but that's what we're
all striving for but injecting this idea
into the criminal justice system that
you could pay off a victim to get your
charges dropped is going to create a
second system of justice for the people
who are either rich or connected or
anything else and then again
what's going to happen down the road
so this person gets away with that crime
because they had enough money Society or
potentially other victims are at risk as
well because that person has not been
held accountable so that's those are the
reasons that we oppose this bill again
we think the system works very well as
it is and we ask you to leave it as is
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony thanks for
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who was not suspended a
pink card
they bring none I hereby close to public
hearing
um
foreign
perfect
right now
so
um
good afternoon uh it being 1 30 I will
open the public hearing for house spill
588fn relative to the criteria for
applying for parole
and
representative Harriet gaththright is
going to introduce it as soon as she
I am Linda gathright from hills 10
um HB 588 was brought to me by a former
inmate
and
after doing a lot of research on it I
decided that it's a great bill
and it's a bill that I'm looking to pass
give you a little background about HP
it's a New Hampshire bill that's totally
Antiquated and an extreme truth in
sentencing policy
and it works as a mechanism to undo many
years of ineffective expensive and
harmful policies
that have contributed
to mass incarceration
and racial disparities in the criminal
as called Truth in sentencing
it came out of a tough on crime era back
in the 1980s
and contributed to mass incarcerations
as I stated before
it's time to reform this harmful policy
it's an expensive policy
it has resulted in people serving longer
sentences at the approximate rate now of
sixty thousand dollars a year
per person
this bill will save money taxpayers
money
this bill does not mean that people will
automatically be released from prison
after serving 50 of their minimum
sentence
it means that they can apply for parole
at that time
this enables the parole board to do a
case by case
analysis
as opposed to truth and sentencing
which imposes a blanket policy on all
individuals
regardless of the circumstances of their
I did make some changes to
um the bill actually were made last term
but some kind of way
um it never came to us this way it's the
original bill that came to us so I did
put through an amendment
um it's in your emails
um
and uh
upstairs fourth floor is supposed to
bring down the the paper copies but if
you check your email for the criminal
justice committee you will see it
on line six of the bill the person was
sentenced to a minimum not less than
five years
um that was changed to seven and a half
years last session so we just updated it
today and the very last
um
18 line 18
this provision of this actually applied
to any person incarcerated on or after
the effective date of this act it is not
retroactive
we also had changed the date from
January to January 1st 2024. that was
the new date so
um
there's other people that will be
testifying that can give you more
details on it but I truly believe that
this is a good bill and it's about time
we do the right thing in New Hampshire
um
and I also can say I don't have the
number and and just for informational
purposes myself and others did sit with
our commissioner at the time that we
decided to do this bill and make quite a
few adjustments and as we read through
the bill
I I think I will take the time and read
through
the first one is the person was
sentenced to a minimum not less than
seven and a half years
the person has no major or a-level
disciplinary violations
the person has not demonstrated a
pattern a repeated disciplinary offenses
that result in an upgrade and
classification level
the person has completed all court and
Department of Corrections required
programs and treatment if given
the person has demonstrated good
paragraph nine shall not apply
if
the person received a sentence that
prohibits him or her from being paroled
the person was convicted of a sexually
violent offense as defined in RSA
135-e colon 2
11.
the person was convicted of committing a
violent crime as defined in RSA 651
also 13 against a person under 18 years
of age
so that's the basis of this
um I'm sure you will hear quite a bit of
testimony
um but I will say that
it's about time taxpayers stop paying
for this and there's a few people that
probably would be eligible for parole or
at least get the opportunity to go
before the parole board and if we
believe our parole board is a great
board I don't believe that they would
release anyone that's not ready to be be
released
thank you representative so just for uh
reference to the committee uh what the
representative speaking of is last year
we heard this bill and there was several
amendments that were made that were
suggestions and unfortunately when this
bill was printed all of those changes
were not put in this bill and that's the
amendment that she is speaking of and
the representative myself went upstairs
to
try to expedite that to be in writing so
it's in front of us we don't actually
have to look at our computers are there
any questions for representative Murphy
thank you madam chair I just want to
clarify that
um line six
um a when you read you read seven and a
half not five years so was that in the
amendment yes thank you
are there any further questions
representative Newman
I might admit search so I just want to
clarify in the the last sentence it
would be striking the word before is
that correct it's so it's not
retroactive right
um we took care of that last session as
well thank you
uh good afternoon uh members of the
committee Madam chairman I'm Donna
scitec I'm from Salem
okay
okay I'm Donna scitec I'm a former
member of this committee a long long
time ago uh former speaker of the house
and a former member of the parole board
so I have a long standing interest in
this subject matter I was there at the
conception 40 years ago when the
legislature adopted truth and sentencing
and I've always said I would come off my
deathbed to save truth and sentencing
this is another
modification of Truth and sentencing
and I think that
having
a state policy where the sentence
imposed by the judge is the sentence
that's actually served
is a good policy I think it has served
us well
there are it has been said that you know
other states have changed there's uh
their their policies but New Hampshire
is proud to maintain some traditions
that are very valuable to us I think
truth and sentencing is one of them
first in the nation primary is another
one
um
no to no income and sales tax these are
New Hampshire values and I believe that
truth and sentencing should be one of
them so I there are four points I want
to make
about this bill
first that this would violate truth and
sentencing because
the judge would impose a sentence of now
seven and a half to a larger number uh
sentence but but the the minimum
sentence of seven and a half wouldn't
mean anything for certain crimes
what is the minimum sentence mean
if it doesn't reflect the actual time
that was imposed by the judge so it
I think that the public would have
confidence in a system that that what
what the judge says and what the judge
imposed is that sentence that's actually
served
the people who would be affected by this
would be those convicted of serious
crimes because you don't get a
sentence of seven and a half
or greater years unless it's a really
serious crime
so we're talking about the most serious
offenders
the there are exclusions for sex
offenders but and there are exclusions
for
crimes committed against somebody who
was under 18 but the the people eligible
for this would still be those might be
convicted of secondary murder
manslaughter negligent homicide first
degree assault strangling kidnapping
human trafficking robbery as long as the
victim wasn't under 18.
I mean are these the people that you
think ought to be considered to have
their their parole hearing after they've
served only 50 percent
uh also it would include a lot of uh
Financial crimes I I remember a case
where there was a gentleman who who was
our own uh Bernie Madoff uh in New
Hampshire he he so many people lost
their their fortunes because he was
running a Ponzi scheme and I mean he got
a serious sentence and he would be
eligible for this and all the victims
we would see that the sentence that was
imposed wasn't the sentence it was
actually served
uh the bill would also uh apply to a lot
of drug crimes the only drug offenses
that get long sentences and the
legislature over the years has increased
the sentences for drug crimes you can
get up to 40 years for some drug crimes
and this bill would apply to them so you
know drug Enterprise leaders uh it's a
sale of drugs with with death resulting
it would apply
um would would be eligible under the
wording of this bill
I want to remind you that current law
already allows for sentence reductions
for all crimes
the goal is to if the goal is to
recognize that people can change and
motivate them to do so there are ample
opportunities under current law RSA 650
120 allows an inmate to ask the court
for a reduction of the minimum after
serving two-thirds of their sentence
this is for everybody
after they serve two-thirds of the
sentence they can go back to the
sentencing judge who has heard all the
testimony who was heard from the victims
who's heard from the defense who's heard
from the prosecution
and they can get a reduction of their
It's Not Unusual it doesn't happen in
every case because I think every inmate
applies for it after the two-thirds but
it is granted if somebody has really
made a turn their life around
the judges will will grant it so that's
under current law for all crimes serve
two-thirds you go back to the judge tell
them hey my situation has changed here's
my plan and the judge has the authority
to Grant it that's under current law
often in Ascent in a sentence
particularly in a drug crime the judge
will impose a sentence and include in
the sentence that you can get a year off
or two years off for completing a drug
program Behind the Walls that's built
into the sentence
and that happens
fairly regularly I I see that at least
when I was on the board
and in the other in the other cases uh
the the judge has allowed the awarding
of earned time credit there are all
kinds of programs that are available to
inmates and they can get time taken off
their sentence by completing their
programs they can get up to I believe
it's up 20 if they completed every kind
of program that was available they can
get up to like 21 months off their
sentence so this is all available
without this bill so somebody who has
turned their life around
can go back to the judge
and say Here's my situation won't you
rethink my my sentence
uh if you think that penalties right now
are too harsh change the the penalties
don't do this back door reduction of of
the penalty
um
this bill if passed would be the same
time it would be the only time that
there's a sentence modification without
the judge's approval
all these others all the other ways you
can reduce your sentence are approved by
the judge this would not require the uh
any uh participation by the judge
and the fourth point I wanted to make
was uh
it should not it should only if you're
going to do it don't make it retroactive
because at the time the sentence was
imposed under current law there were
certain expectations on the part of the
victim it would maybe part of a plea
bargain negotiation you know if you'll
plead guilty to a second-degree assault
we won't charge you with first degree
assault
so
this will change that so I'm happy to
hear the sponsors say that it would
apply prospectively only because you
have to look at what this means to
victims
when victims come in it's like
the crime just happened yesterday they
go right back to the the time that it
happened it's really painful to see them
having to go through this
so keep in mind the effect
on victims for people who are sentenced
to pretty serious
pretty lengthy sentences and to have to
cycle them through all of this
every time that they get a parole
hearing so I'd respectfully ask the
committee to find this bill in expedient
to legislate and I try to answer any
thank you representative Rhodes thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question Madam speaker you had mentioned
that if a if a person that was in prison
has already done this good behavior and
so forth that they could ask the judge
about a lesser sentence what what would
that look like how would that person go
about contacting that judge oh they they
file a motion uh and they fill out their
reasons for it it makes a lot do it
themselves some they have family they
hire the family might hire a lawyer to
do it for him but I've seen uh
applications by inmates that get it to
the judge they spell out all the good
things they've done and their behavior
has been wonderful and they've got a job
and they've got a place to go and the
judge looks at it and says well okay
maybe we'll take two years off your
sentence
okay
um if I may ask what um what what
success rate do you see in that how
not a lot
um
I think when I I there are other members
of the board here I I don't know how it
is no I've been off the board for a year
but I would see you know
maybe maybe a couple of times a month
that it was successful or that yeah it
was successful okay because I think all
of them ask for it
and um as a as a follow-up does the um
the board get input into that when
someone asks outside of the board to the
directly to the judge
when somebody is scheduled for a parole
hearing uh victims are notified the
County Attorney is notified
no I mean if someone asks the judge to
reduce their sentence without by going
around the board to make a motion to
have their sentence reviewed the does
the board get notified and have input
into that no no we only see him if the
judge has granted it okay thank you and
when we see we would see a lot of people
who had applied for it and said I didn't
get my two-thirds that's why I'm here
today you know
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um I was hoping just to clarify some of
your testimony
um I think earlier you characterized
um the legislation as backdoor reduction
of penalty and I was curious if you
could um speak to how that contrasts
from the existing
parole system and and maybe why you
don't view the existing parole system as
a backdoor reduction of penalty thank
you when the judge imposes a sentence he
says you're served a minimum of certain
number of time and a maximum
and that's what everybody expects is
going to happen on the sentencing
document it's called the Minimus the
judge has the spells out what he's what
he wants the sentence to be he can also
check off are they eligible for earn
time credit not everybody is eligible
but but the judge is the one who decides
so
here you have a document saying you're
sentenced to seven and a half to Fifteen
and that's what everybody expects and
you might get some time off for earn
time and the the there is awareness that
there is the ability to uh have a
two-thirds reduction
but nowhere on there
on the sentencing document does it say
uh you could get 50 off if you've been a
representative selling
thank you so much
thank you madam speaker and I'm sure
you've recognized the greetings I bring
you as well
um I'm curious with people who apply for
parole
um what percentage of people who have
committed crimes you referenced as being
um worthy of very extended sentences
what percentage of them actually are
granted parole
New Hampshire has a very high parole
rate and uh I think maybe J Mackey will
be testifying can give you the number
we parole much
our parole rate is much higher than in
we Grant parole more often
I want to say
68 to 72 percent yeah
okay
representative Newell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I just wanted to clarify because I
think the terminology is similar
um mandatory minimum versus you know
mandatory minimum being what
um what a what would be imposed on a
judge right that for a certain uh
certain crimes there's a mandatory
minimum this is this is saying what the
judge chooses to impose based on that
crime
based on that specific situation that's
a question is very has very few
mandatory minimums okay
[Music]
so I'm not sure yeah let me I'm sorry
let me let me let me say it a little
clear
what I'm saying is is uh are we talking
about
um something that was handed down to the
judge that was
um not dependent on the specific
situation at hand just based on if you
are convicted of this crime you there is
mandatory minimum that is set for that
across the board what we're talking
about here if I'm correct so tell me if
I'm right or wrong is this is what the
judge
um heard all of the evidence in this
particular crime took all things into
consideration and then and then uh set
this this minimum right okay thank you I
representative Bradley
when you sentencing in New Hampshire
back in the 80s the individual that was
on Parole and inspired the introduction
would they be eligible for parole
20. she was 20.
um
I don't know whether he was convicted of
first-degree murder or a second degree
murder yeah it was first degree murder
yeah
he'd be eligible he wouldn't be eligible
under this because first degree murder
is excluded okay
follow up
so let's say that this provision didn't
exist
and a person applied for parole at their
original minimum parole date and they
could check the box at all these
criteria behaviorally as Parole Board
um Madam speaker you don't have to
answer that that goes to specific like
specific cases okay if you want to ask
about the law go ahead no that's okay
I just have a question on on the 50
that's in the new law can people now
apply with a minimum sentence apply for
a parole and
how does that work
right now they're eligible for parole at
their minimum
at the minimum at their minimum so this
would reduce the fifty percent you're
eligible for parole at your minimum
thank you and and they can chip away at
their eligibility for parole by earned
time credits
by completing certain programs
so so the minimum changes
just for clarification for the committee
so if someone has a minimum of 10
they can reduce that minimum by
completing the programs yeah thank you
representative Newman you may follow up
foreign
the other question was is there are
there are minimum sentences uh listed
for various crimes
and when the person is convicted
the judge has the potential to assign a
punishment of less than whatever the
minimum is at that time is that correct
I'm not I'm not not sure
I know that the penalties for a class a
felony I believe are seven and a half
minimum and for a
help me Roger
yeah three and a half for a class B
felony
but
representative Newman are you asking if
the judge has the ability to lower a
minimum sentence to a plea bargain I'm
I'm talking about you having minimum
sentence that is assigned but are there
can can the punishment given even though
there is a minimum sentence and not one
that has been put in the law with the
particular to that law this is an
absolute minimum they can give less than
that they can give less than what the
minimum is that's defined generally for
um
okay uh Mr chair committee members Aubry
Friedman from Bridgewater private person
um I support this bill
um
I like the idea of uh
first of all it pretty much excludes
violent crimes so or super violent
crimes so you know we're not talking
about releasing uh you know serial
murders and that type of uh person on
the street
um that definitely excludes that so how
many years a person spends in prison
it's pretty arbitrary who knows if they
could be there five years ten years they
might reform in a couple years they
might never reform it's pretty arbitrary
so if a person has had good behavior
they're not they seem to have been
reformed themselves you know they're
I say why not give them a second chance
what's the advantage of having them
staying in prison wasting away for years
they're uh is not serving Society
um they have my family they you know
they could be supporting and be I say
give them a second chance earlier to uh
at least the chance to get out earlier
and and start your life over again and
be a productive member of society so I
think that's a good idea
um as a secondary thing there is a
savings to the taxpayer it's a 64
000 233 minus 688 so it's about 63 000
that's so that's nice but that's you
know significant but that's the
secondary advantage to not keeping
people in prison longer that is not
serving Society the only thing I would
mention on this bill that I think needs
an amendment or maybe I'm not
understanding it correctly is
um
this is in
sir that's probably not the correct
version there is an amended version
coming so okay but I haven't heard this
part mentioned yet so I I want to bring
it up this is in paragraph uh this is
under uh x 10. uh it talks about shall
not apply if and this is under section c
the person was convicted of committing a
violent crime as defined in RSA and then
that RSA lists violent you know arson
and all these various very violent crime
it says except against a person under 18
years of age
now I don't understand why that to me
that land those that last little phrase
shouldn't be there why is age if you
commit a violent crime whether it's a
five-year-old or a 25 year old or a 100
somebody 50 or whatever what's the
difference it's a violent crime why
should the age be significant it's a
violent crime and that's it so I I don't
understand why that last little phrase
is in there this would actually exclude
more people actually uh but I think if
it's going to be a violent crime it's a
violent crime so that's I would maybe
mention that as an amendment but
otherwise I think the intent of the bill
is good and I support it
and that's it uh thank you any questions
this is on yes all right sorry I
apologize
thank you um I mean I sit before you in
support of this bill as a private
citizen I was formally incarcerated I
actually did 15 years in prison uh here
in Concord I was released about three
years ago I went through the uh the
system uh
being housed in Concord being housed in
Berlin also going to minimum security
the halfway house
I
actually got some relief
with the 65120 and a combination with
the earn time credit however I feel that
those two laws alone are not enough to
help alleviate the situation that we're
facing in the state with the prison
system which is
um lack of resources we're at the max in
the prison as far as you know Staffing
and how many people we can house by the
same time the programs that we have in
the state of New Hampshire are very
limited and I feel this bill repealing
or replacing
a move in the positive direction for the
State of New Hampshire
I know there's a lot of concerns
but I feel that what we have in place
with parole is is a great defense in
regards to the fears that many of us
have releasing the wrong people folks
that are inside right now that are
aren't doing anything would not get this
relief they would go to the parole board
and most likely get denied
and uh the folks that are doing the
right thing they will get the
recognition that they need there's folks
that
so there's this false sense that 650 120
or the earn time credits is uh
the judges recognize who needs to be
released and unfortunately that's not
that's not always the case obviously
from County to County Judge to judge
there's a lot of room for
um
uh subjective interpretations of the law
in which folks that I know personally
that I feel or I know have done the
right things are still struggling to to
get that relief and a friend of mine
actually is now in the process with the
state
Supreme Court with appealing the
decision that he was denied both 650 120
and earn time credit bills which is a
grieving Justice when there's folks that
don't do anything just sit you know all
day in their cells and we'll go to the
parole board and we'll get it just
because they didn't get any tickets in
the past 90 days
and you know they didn't commit any new
crimes while they were incarcerated
so again I just um I am in support of
this bill and I hope you folks will too
thank you
could you uh would you mind telling us
what some of the programs you took
advantage of were yes sir
um
unfortunately some of the programs that
I took no longer exist when I first came
in I was uh I had courts
um how do you say I'm sorry
Court referred programs that with the
amount of time I did I was originally
sent this to 18 years completed 15.
some of those laws by the time I came
close enough to be eligible to
participate in those programs they no
longer existed and they were actually
waived but I was able to do some things
on my own uh one of the programs which
again no longer exists in New Hampshire
is the Alternatives the violence
projects
um
which was a a conflict resolution uh
course uh it was it's made up of several
workshops that are two to three days
long again conflict resolution
communicate uh you know building
communication skills
um Community Building
etc etc but again fortunately that
program no longer exists I also
participated in the Hobbycraft program
which is run by the recreation
Recreation Department in the prison
which allowed folks to um
first of all it was incentive based you
had to be right up free you would have a
job you were putting on a waiting list
as long as you maintain those things you
entered this program where you had the
choice of uh learning how to build
Furniture arts and crafts
um jewelry making and it also allowed
you to
uh
make money legitimately because of the
retail store
some other programs I participated in
whereas anger management
I was also a student at the high school
the Concord has its own high school the
prison I'm sorry
so I was able to get my high school
diploma
geez there's a lot of things that I I
did I wish I had brought something I
could show you folks but again not
everybody is super motivated a lot of
these programs were volunteer based they
were not mandatory uh and again the the
main reason for that was because of the
lack of resources that we have again
Staffing is an issue
um it's just a trickle-down effect
unfortunately if um if you go back and
look at when this law was passed
originally the truth and sentencing law
the population of the prison was like
two three hundred people and now we're
talking about you know 2 000 plus folks
between the several facilities we've had
to add more facilities but in that same
amount of time the population of the pr
of the state has changed very little and
the crime rate has been more or less the
same however the population has of the
prison has increased and I believe that
it's directly because of Truth and
sentencing
and one more question for me the
programs that you availed yourself of
while you were incarcerated have you
been able to apply those to help you
since you've been out were they
beneficial to you once you get outside
yes
and no
I would say there are some things that
obviously they stick with you that do
not need practice or you don't need
anything to practice with and what I
mean by that is uh there are some
courses I took in there that had to do
with technology unfortunately there's
very limited
um employment opportunities Behind the
Walls that allow you to utilize that so
I was able to take advantage of that
um but not everybody is one of the
positions that I held was a clerk for
the recreation department in which I was
basically you know had access to the
computer you know printing documents
emailing documents under supervision of
Staff of course
um and I was able to utilize some of the
other skills that I learned while there
but a lot of things that you just
unfortunately can't
um because there again there's nothing
to follow up with in order to to apply
those skills that you learn while you're
in there
representative sailing
thank you Mr chair
um
I'm good and if the skills that you
developed between the high school
program and the system and some of the
others allowed for you to have supported
employment once you were able to earn
your release
that's a great question to Mom so I was
23 years old when I was originally
incarcerated
um
some of the skills that I learned could
be I could have I couldn't I guess you
could say apply but unfortunately one of
the big things that is is lacking is
um
you know connections with the community
so as far as being able to find uh
gainful employment was a challenge for
me I I literally had no idea what I was
going to do when I got out I was willing
to do just about anything legitimately
in order to to support myself and my
family
um but I would say some of the the
positives were because of my in
participation some of the program in
there is kind of networking build you
know getting to meet folks that
volunteered that once I was outside that
I was able to reconnect with them they
were able to help me find a meaningful
employment but uh again one of the
programs I did to participate in while I
was was locked up was um in minimum
security was with the dot program and
actually was able to gain employment
through that through them but again not
something that I felt was uh
complementary to to my my skills but it
was something that was steady you know
got me outside
um making a steady income but again
these are opportunities that are very
limited very limited and uh
I could have been exposed to a lot
sooner had uh truth and sentencing I've
been been an obstacle and again again so
when I say I did get some relief from
650 120 and from the earn time credit it
was very limited uh so earn time credit
the max amount of time that you can get
off is 21 months however the only way
that you can maximize that at the time
that I was I was inside was college
you'd have to take college courses and
you'd have to get a an association or a
Bachelors
in order to to realize or or have that
um
be able to
be eligible for the the full 21 months
so I got 10 months
um from that and then the uh truth and
sentence I mean truth consensus in the
um I could have got six years is what I
would have been eligible for that was a
third of my sentence that could have got
suspended unfortunately at that time the
process it took me about a year before I
could get into court because I was
seeking approval from uh the
commissioner and um just the whole
process again of going to courts so I
would have never realized the full six
years at the time that I did see get in
front of a judge I would have been
eligible for five and I received two and
as grateful as I am for that relief I
felt that I deserved the whole five
years again if I had a resume of the the
amount of things that I did while I was
in prison that were positive you know
programs volunteering Etc
um
you know I had some of my peers say if
you if you're not going to get the full
five years then who's gonna get the full
five years and again it's one of those
things where it's very subjective
depending on the judge and the county
that you belong to and even maybe the
I guess the notoriety beyond your your
crime unfortunately
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I don't mean to put
you on the spot and ask you to speak for
for anybody else so I apologize about
how that's how this comes off you had
mentioned that you went through the the
programs and did what you were supposed
to do and and took these classes can you
give me an example other than yourself
how many people you were incarcerated
with
that did the same approximate percentage
I would that is a tough question
um
it's a minority it is a minority
and maybe this is a very conservative
number I would say you know two three
percent
folks
representative Newell
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
coming here I really appreciate you
coming and sharing your story and I'm
just curious if looking at the
parameters of the bill would this have
um
I believe I believe so again I'm not
fully I don't know the exact details but
I believe so I would okay and I don't I
don't want to get you personal or
anything like that so so yeah thank you
I appreciate it you're welcome
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chair
speaker scitec former speaker scitec
brought up uh how victims could be
re-traumatized from something like do
you see how we could balance the
concerns of those individuals who may be
traumatized from an event that had
happened and how we could rehabilitate
the people that are incarcerated the
balance between uh the trauma that
they're affecting that they have and the
rehabilitative process for the
incarcerated individual
no I absolutely I feel there are steps
that can can be taken to prevent that
because that is a very
um important concern
um for the victims and even for the the
offenders themselves you know to have to
relive that you know because
you know it's traumatizing on both sides
obviously
um
you know of good behavior you know
having having done the extra work in
order to be eligible for parole
um and I think that is the step
beforehand to just you can kind of
filter out who would be prepared to get
that that 50 relief
um and if not then then they shouldn't
be in front of them in front of the poor
the chair recognizes his attorney Andres
and
struts and
thank you we thought we'd come up
together to try to answer all of your
questions at the same time
um our office does oppose this bill and
I'll explain why and then we'll answer
any questions that you have
first it's not clear why this bill is
necessary when I read the bill
I tried to discern what the what the
purpose is what's behind it and I
contacted the Department of Corrections
the commissioner Helen Hanks and I asked
her for the numbers of incarcerated
individuals in New Hampshire and I found
out that the last nine years that number
has dropped 30 percent
30 percent drop in nine years so there
is no issue with mass incarceration in
New Hampshire we're actually
incarcerating lost unless people each
and every year so that can't be a
justification for the bill
um
we have a rigorous and thorough
sentencing system in New Hampshire and
we live that system and we can explain
to you how it works
um one of the questions that came from
representative talked asked about I
think about mandatory sentences or
minimum sentences
almost no crime in New Hampshire has a
mandatory minimum sentence almost none
an example is first degree murder which
is a mandatory life without parole but
almost every single sentence in New
Hampshire is the result of a long
deliberate thorough process that process
involves the judge listening to both
sides considering the facts from both
sides hearing victim input and applying
the law that applies to sentencing in
New Hampshire that is the process that
creates a sentence in New Hampshire it
is a very deliberate process it's not
spontaneous and it's something that has
input from all sides and this bill would
undo it it would undo it because not
only because it gives people a chance to
cut their senses in half but because
that comes on top of a system that
already provides for multiple reviews of
sentences and reductions so first of all
if someone is convicted they can
obviously appeal the legality of their
sentence to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court that can be part of the appeal
process second they have What's called
the sentence review board and in New
Hampshire that's a three-judge panel
that reviews sentences they can raise
the sentence lower the sentence or leave
it the same but defendants have the
right to that process in New Hampshire
you've heard about this chance to get up
to 21 months off that's called earn time
credits inmates have the chance to do a
variety of different things and many of
these things are not very rigorous
they're not college degrees they're just
classes seminars in the prison that are
approved and in total they can get 21
months off almost two years off their
sense
the last thing is that the law provides
something called sentence reduction
which is an RSA 651 colon 20. and that
allows someone to petition to have their
Senate reduced by up to one-third so
there are a combination of things in
place that allows a convicted individual
to have their propriety of their
sentence reviewed and potentially
reduced and those all exist and we don't
think there's a reason to add additional
ones there's no blanket policy here that
incarcerates people instead judges have
broad discretion to consider the facts
of the case what the victim wants what
the state recommends what the defense
wants the defendant's background all
those things go into it and then the
judge applies the law in the case
something that's important to remember
here is that I think this was said that
you know the average person New
Hampshire unless they commit a really
horrific crime right out of the gate
they're not getting a seven and a half
year prison sentence out of the gate
that person may very well be a repeat
offender and this bill would not take
that into account
so you may have somebody who's committed
multiple offenses and finally a judge
says you know what I'm going to give you
a 10 to 20 year sentence
that person has got to that point
because of what they've done in the past
and then this bill would essentially
just cut that in half
um
there was a statement made about the
fact that about this bill addressing
violent crimes and that's one of the
issues that we see with this bill this
bill has a carve out for some violent
offenses
in a lot of States when these bills are
proposed the idea is we want to we want
to free people who have haven't
committed violent offenses we want to we
want to give the chance for non-violent
offenders to get out early
this bill does just the opposite because
what it does is there's a carve out
but the carve out is only for some
violent offenders so the bill says you
can't you can't get the chance to reduce
your sentence but only if you commit
certain crimes against victims who are
under the age of 18. so if you murder
someone who's 18 if you set someone's
house on fire if he's 18
. if you beat and break the bones of
someone who's 18 you get the opportunity
to reach your sentence but if that
victim is 17 you don't get that
opportunity
I believe a private individuals spoke
and talked about that issue and we agree
if you if you're going to consider a
bill like this what at least makes
conceptual sense to say would apply only
to non-violent offenders and there would
be a way to come up with a list of what
those non-violent offenders would be but
otherwise the bill creates two separate
classes based on the age of the victim
and certainly whether you're if you're
17 and you get murdered or you're 18 and
you get murdered or beaten or anything
else that one year doesn't make much of
a difference given given what's happened
to you so again if you're going to
consider making an exclusion based on
that we think the exclusion should be
for all violent crimes meaning the only
non-violent offenders should be eligible
here
last thing to say is just
philosophically
doing the right thing after you've
committed a crime or horrific crimes
series of horrific crimes doesn't make
up for what you did to get there in the
first place the system does recognize
that people can reform can rehabilitate
can help themselves and they get
benefits from that they get benefits in
prison by getting privileges by having
the chance to reduce their sentences
they get those benefits
um but the question is whether or not
somebody is going to keep getting
multiple benefits time and time again
for doing what's expected of all of us
which is just obey the rules and don't
hurt people and so there's a fundamental
issue with this which is to say how many
times do you get the benefit of just
doing what we ask you to do when the
reason you're there is because you did
the exact opposite there has to be some
have to be some repercussions for that
conduct
and our system in New Hampshire already
recognizes that we will win all that
down that it can be reduced but we feel
that this bill simply goes too far and
should not include violent offenders at
the lease and I'll turn to attorney
Andress and see if he wants to add
things and then we'll have to thank you
the only thing I would add is as
attorney strolls and said judges have
wide discretion in sentencing
what doesn't make sense to me in this is
that the minimum has to be seven and a
half years in order for this bill to
apply
so if a person was sentenced to 5 to 15
years in the New Hampshire State Prison
they would be eligible for parole after
they served their minimum five years but
if a person was sentenced to seven and a
half to 15 years in the New Hampshire
State Prison under this bill they'd be
eligible to apply for parole after three
and three quarter years
so you'd end up in a situation where
if you were serving less than seven and
a half years as your minimum you had
essentially truth in sentencing but over
seven and a half years it was really it
was half that and certainly judges would
understand that and the difficulty is if
a judge felt that someone should spend
10 years in prison instead of doing for
example a 10 to 20 where the judge knows
the person would be eligible for parole
after five years you may have judges
imposing a 20 to 40 sentence
so that the person did actually spend 10
years incarcerated
that's really all I had
to anybody has any questions yeah I a
couple quick points you mentioned the
sentence review board and you said that
they could increase so if a defendant
has found himself guilty and they got a
sentence that they think was a little
too harsh and they apply to this they're
kind of is are they are they really
rolling the dice they could end up with
a harsher sentence because they asked
that so the Central View Board can do
three things they can maintain the
sentence they can reduce it or increase
it and you can look at their statistics
I think 98 plus they leave they
sometimes reduce and rarely do they
increase so the vast majority of the
time it's probably staying in the same
range of reducing but yeah there's
there's a risk with that which is that
it certainly could be increased
in my my last question
um when you were talking about the
different ways that someone is there's
also uh correct me if I'm wrong the
potential for asking for a clemency or
pardon from the the executives that also
so the way it works in New Hampshire uh
there's a governance constitutional
right to Grant a pardon but also
clemency or a sentence reduction those
are rare but they sometimes happen but I
would say my experience pretty rare
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question and Mr chairman if I
may just have a second because I have to
frame this I apologize
last week we heard
we heard a bill and
um your your friend was testifying and
gave us some examples of some things
that may not be considered violent and a
lot of people in the committee were like
what right so he'd mentioned arson may
not be considered violated kidnapping
may not be considered violent I took
that as if
a parent maybe doesn't have custody of
their kid and they kidnap them that
might not be considered violent and the
other thing with arson is
I guess it could be a discretionary
maybe the building was vacant and that
would be a reason it would not be
considered vacant I mean violent so with
with that being said my question is
you're mentioning about
you know violent crimes maybe that not
being considered so would that mean that
violent crimes May
be discretionary or or judgmental or
just you don't understand my question I
do thank you so you heard me mention our
sin and other crimes the bill has a
definition of what violent crimes means
but that that is too limited in our view
so if we if you're going to revise this
bill the suggestion would be that you
actually include things like arson
second-degree assault major drug dealing
case especially drug cases that result
in deaths because for example as a
prosecutor arson I've argued look maybe
there was nobody in the building but you
put the firefighters at risk who are
going there to put out that fire so I
agree with you there is there are a
class of other serious offenses that
should be included in that list of
violent offenses
um again if if the idea is to give the
most deserving people a chance
potentially reducing their sentence you
would seem to want to include
non-violent offenders in that group only
but again the legislature could craft a
definition of violent offenses and and
add or remove whatever they saw fit in
that definition
you're welcome
represent Zimmer
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chair um I was just wondering
since you said that the sentence review
board 98 of the time keeps the sentence
the same is that actually an effective
way that we currently have available to
us to reduce sentences for offenders
it is effective because if the goal is
to check and see whether judges are
making the right decision that tells you
that three other people reviewed that
sentence and found that the judge did in
fact make the correct decision because
the idea of that sense review board is
to correct what they see as
inappropriate decisions so I think you
should be heartened by the fact that
three completely independent experienced
judges looked at all the facts of the
case and said you know what we think the
Judge made the appropriate decision here
so I think again what that affirms is
that our current system is working
extremely well in New Hampshire I think
if you saw if the number was 98 were
corrected I think that we would be
concerned about the fact that our system
isn't working appropriately so again
this is actually a check that confirms
that judges are actually getting it
right
representative Newell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I was actually uh reached out to by a
constituent so I feel like I have a
little bit of a responsibility to ask
about this as somebody who's been
following this for I think they said it
was through for three years that this
has been coming up every year um and
last year it came within two votes I
believe
um my question is is that the way it was
presented to me the last two years the
AG hasn't taken a position on it and
this year have chosen to oppose it and
so I'm just wondering what's the
difference between the last two years
and in this year what what prompted uh
you to take a position on this this year
well easy enough thank you there's
sometimes there's sometimes a change in
philosophy about
um our role
last year we were we we were approached
and said hey it would be helpful to have
you at least come over and answer
questions about bills
um and so you know we try to we try to
be careful about our role uh and then
I've been in the office 22 plus years
there have been times I've come over in
the past other times you know not
um but we've
we've definitely tried to monitor bills
and pick the bills that we think really
impact Justice on a Statewide basis in
New Hampshire and also try to figure out
can we at least come over we're not
going to take a position and at least
answer your questions and be as helpful
as we can whatever our opinion is and
we'll do that on some bills as well
where we say we're not taking a position
we're just happy to provide whatever
information you can
and we've also reached out to the other
County attorneys and I can indicate the
Merrimack County attorney Halverson
opposes the bill Cheshire county
attorney McLaughlin opposes the Bill
Carroll County attorney andrewsy opposes
the bill of kawas County attorney
McCormick opposes the bill Belknap
County attorney Livernois poses the bill
Rockingham County attorney Conway
opposed it and Grafton the County
Attorney Marshall Hornick also indicated
um
I thought and I may have misheard you
may say something about
um
this bill cuts the sentence in half but
the wording as I read it is that it
doesn't cut anything it really only
gives you the right to apply for parole
and the parole can make a decision to
Grant a parole right away or it can deny
the parole and it so it doesn't really
cut it in half it just has to do with
the application when the application for
parole can be made is that am I wrong
and understanding it that way
no
I mean I think that's a that's a fair
assessment of it it allows you to apply
for parole
um in half the time that it would
normally take you to apply for parole if
your minimum sentence was seven and a
follow-up
so
does it allow you in half the time or is
it to allow you just in half the time or
whatever the minimum sentence is maybe I
don't understand so normally under the
system now if you're sentenced to seven
and a half to 15 years you can apply for
parole after seven and a half years
under this bill if you were sentenced to
seven and a half to 15 years you could
apply for parole in three and three
quarter years which is half of seven and
a half
but if you had a minimum sentence of
less than seven and a half this wouldn't
necessarily affect you so if you had a
minimum of say five to fifty a cents of
five to Fifteen you'd have to wait the
full five years to apply for parole
so you'd actually have this scenario
where if you had a five to Fifteen
it would take you you'd have to wait
five years to apply for parole but if
you had a seven and a half to Fifteen
you could apply for parole in three and
three quarter years
you actually have the ability to get
approached sooner Mr chair could I ask
to quick while and follow up on the same
subject
so on the same surgery let's just go up
to the I'm a little bit confused about
what the what the maximum sentences are
I've heard they could increase it to 10
to 40 or 10 to whatever and and my
question is is that just at the
discretion of the judge or is there
something that
that the maximum may not be the maximum
as defined for a specific crime it
depends on the particular crime some
some statutes set a maximum for instance
homicide cases it may be a maximum of
life for class B felonies the maximum is
three and a half to seven years class A
felonies seven and a half to 15 years so
the particular law May establish what
the actual maximum is in the judge can't
exceed that
and that's similar to the to the minimum
can also be in the law and that is
that's a hard those two would be hard
maximum and minimum yeah it just sets a
minimum and a maximum but again very
very few crimes in New Hampshire to have
a mandatory minimum so a judge can go
anywhere from zero up to the maximum on
thank you for your testimony thank you
for listening we appreciate the
thank you the chair recognizes Jay
foreign
Mr chairman I'm Roger Phillipson
um chairman of the Adult Parole Board
um but J Mack Eaton uh is our director
of operations but he also has a
background
in
working at at the prison in
classifications which is extremely
important and I think he has a number of
things to say and I will turn it over to
him I think would be a big help to the
committee
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
provide some testimony I said my name is
Jay Mackey I'm the director of
operations for the New Hampshire Del
parole board I have been in the field of
Corrections for a little bit of
background for 24 years now I started as
a corrections officer field training
officer cert team member defensive
tactics instructor youth counselor and
Juvenile Justice to being over at the
prison as a case manager and civilian at
civilian duty to working as a supervisor
of federal records and administrative
classification so uh first half of my
career is based on
providing security for the staff and the
inmates and and the community and
keeping people incarcerated the second
half was more of working with the
inmates to try to get them released and
working to make sure that they are fit
to be released so I've seen Corrections
from all angles
um of the spectrum
um
I've submitted some written testimony I
won't go through all three pages but
I'll try to Briefly summarize a lot of
it
um
I know we testified earlier about you
know the operations of the New Hampshire
Del parole board this bill as written
may not have a significant impact on us
but if there are any amendments made it
could result in US needing to have more
hearings more staff to provide for the
increased workload and even increase the
membership to more than five members
depending upon if any of this criteria
I I was here on behalf of the doc in
2021 when this bill was first introduced
there were no amendments to it it was
just you know eligible approve at 50 it
was opposed by the doc at the time I was
here last year with former chairperson
Jennifer Sergeant on behalf of the
parole board when the amendments were
made with all this criteria in there and
we opposed it back then as well based
off of the The increased workload and
and all that other type of issues that
are documented in this this written
testimony
um
excuse me as has been stated multiple
times by multiple people uh there is
already in place
um processes and procedures for mh2 be
able to reduce their sentences as has
been said at RSA 65120 the amendment was
made I believe last year where the
inmates could actually apply up to a
year before their two-thirds date which
would allow them if granted they could
start working on their re-entry
programming and all that type of stuff
which is was a very good idea I believe
as a doc we supported it when it was
first introduced
um
excuse me and with the earn time credit
I know uh Mr Pineda had testified and
there has been testimony by I believe Mr
lascaz is here as well there
experiences of being unable to get that
much earn time credit and that is true
for their experiences
um I can definitely testify that that
was absolutely true but in this
testimony we do have some statistics of
earn time credit that has been recently
in 2020 only 274 inmates received earn
time credit and that was back when the
population of the of the gocu is uh
around 2500 to 2000 to 3 000. in 2021
over 1400 inmates received our time
credit
um and then last year just under 800 790
MH received runtime credit uh a possible
result of that lower number is the
commissioner did do a lot of work in
researching how
the on-time creditors being manipulated
through the tablet system and making it
a little bit tougher
um or making sure that the people are
doing the appropriate programs to get
the credit off their sentence as well as
the lower number of inmates that are
actually incarcerated at the
um in the New Hampshire doc
when covet hit the two years after covet
there's been a decrease of at least 600
inmates
currently at the doc as attorney
strelsen mentioned about the Arizona
mass incarceration issue in New
Hampshire the numbers at the New
Hampshire State Prison are extremely low
where units are being shut down
which helps with their Extreme Staffing
issues but as well as when I was the
administrative classifications we had a
200 person wait list for people waiting
to go out to the transitional work
center for minimum security
there's 162 beds at that at that house
there's only 80 inmates in there because
there's nobody else right now that
qualifies
um so it's definitely it's definitely a
different shift in demographics and
inmates now with the total amount of
inmates and
um
you know with this the amount of
opportunities they have through earn
time credit is
um a whole lot more than they had in the
past
with RC 65120 it won't be too much on
that
um
now yes I in my experience working in
the federal records classifications I've
seen many people approved for it and
those are the people that absolutely
have earned it that as was described the
processes they petition the court now
they can do it up to a year before the
two-thirds date they petition the court
they detail everything that they've done
the court contacts a doc for synopsis of
their incarceration to confirm all of
the stuff that they have done and then
that goes through the prosecution the
victims all have input and obviously the
judge has input as well I've seen many
people granted I've seen people not
granted and for reasons such as
they commend the individual for all
their rehabilitative efforts but at the
time of sentencing this was a fair and
just sentence that was handed down that
was fully negotiated in a plea deal and
they saw no reason to lower that
sentence at the time
um so you know one of the one of the
reasons that they do for denial most of
the time they're denied is because they
haven't actually made enough efforts at
Rehabilitation
um and obviously if this bill was passed
the person like I wouldn't be granted
parole either
um
you know in plea agreements again you
know as attorney Andrews had mentioned
you know I've talking with prosecutors
myself where they said yeah he could
have got a 7.5 to 15 but we thought with
the goals of of uh sentencing New
Hampshire being punishment deterrence
Rehabilitation they thought those goals
were met with a five to ten year
sentence they only wanted the person to
do five years
in cases like this where they may be
asking for more years now because if
this bill is passed so they can get that
certain amount of incarceration a
certain amount of punishment that they
deem is is just
um to enable them to get that but if
that person is now sentenced to seven
and a half to Fifteen
instead of the five or four year
sentence they may have gotten
they may pick up some disciplinary
issues while at the prison and will now
have to serve that full seven and a half
at least until they apply for parole
which was not the intent
of The Plea negotiations in the
beginning so I believe this will have a
whole issue an issue with plea
negotiations
one of the criteria is that the
individuals need to complete their doc
or Court required programs
the way programs are done and the way
inmates are assessed for programs is by
your minimum parole date
you need to be completing your programs
when you're close to getting out so you
can retain that information and those
skills that you learned and work on them
while you're reintegrating the community
being eligible for Pearl of 50 is not a
guarantee
so people will not be getting assessed
most likely I can't speak for the doc on
this but in my experience people will
not be getting assessed for these
programs until they're closer to their
100 minimum
because I know inmates in the past have
asked to be assessed for a program
because they want to apply for their
two-thirds to the court and because
that's not a guarantee the program says
no because if we put you through you do
the program and you get denied your
two-thirds you have another three years
before your eligible to be in the
community and you'll have to go through
the program again
so this this will cause an issue with
programming now may require the doc to
make changes where they do
assess somebody a lot earlier than they
would have and maybe that pressure goes
through the program will have to do it
again if they don't qualify for parole
at that time
um
one of the biggest issues and one of the
things I've seen in my entire career is
working through the system Mr Pineda
mentioned it about going through the
transition work center in the halfway
house and how that you know someone with
him who had been incarcerated for about
15 years that is extremely necessary so
and the people we're talking about in
this bill will have been incarcerated
for at least three four years before
they're eligible
if they're if they have done enough work
to be granted parole
they won't they'll be granted parole
before being eligible to go out to
minimum security
and all they're going to need after
being granted parole is a housing plan
approved
most of the reason we see now when when
some inmates are granted they're
two-thirds they
don't elect to go through the
classification system to work on
re-entry they call their buddies they
call their family members who said hey
can you have me live there when I get
released
you know instead of being able to get a
job in the community whether they're
halfway house or working on a trade
while they're at transitional work
center Mr need to talk about working for
the Department of Transportation there's
multiple Crews that go out now for that
and I know of at least one person off
the top of my head that continued with
that job afterwards
um when he was released on parole
this may deprive some of those inmates
of that ability or
when they're posed with that opportunity
they won't take the the way to go to
help working on that reintegration they
will say oh well if I can get out now
mom can I come live there you know hey
Uncle Joe can I come live at your house
for a little while
and if it's approved it looks like a
suitable residence then they they're
able to be released
um
so
yeah
I believe I've touched on just about
everything that I've seen here in other
questions that may have Arisen
throughout this that I've hopefully been
able to answer I am open to any
questions you may have
thank you you mentioned a little bit
earlier in your testimony that there
were 80 out of 160 beds available at one
of the facilities where they could earn
more time and you said the reason being
just not enough people were qualified or
would qualify for that can you explain
what that just briefly what what the
qualifications would be and why they're
not reading it yep so to be minimal
security it's called C2 status the
classification levels through the system
are C1 Work Release to up to C5 maximum
security C2 is minimum security it's
outside the the main prison it's called
the transitional work center where you
work most of the jobs there you're
working on the campuses of the
facilities or you could work at the
retail store you can work at the
Department of Transportation on road
crews you can work with Sergeant Johnson
does road crews goes into the community
paints municip municipal buildings and
you know stuff like that
um
to be eligible for C2 and I should have
touched on it it's in my written
testimony you need to be at least two
years to your minimum parole date
so right now classifications doesn't
have enough people that are that close
to the minimum parole date that meet
other qualifications as well to go out
there one of the qualifications you need
to complete your intensive programming
so if you're a sex offender you need to
complete your sex offender treatment if
you are deemed as needing intensive drug
treatment you need a complete Focus
program before you can go out there
um okay yeah like I said we had a wait
list when I was a case manager it was
widely known that once somebody was
granted C2 approved C2 they were waiting
three months before they went out to the
transitional work center now there's no
weight now they're trying to push not
push people out there but they're trying
to fill the beds be because it is a very
good place to go for rehabilitation
representative wheeler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and for all the
information about the parole board you
gave us I think that's very helpful not
just for this legislation but in general
um what is the standard that the parole
board uses for rehabilitation how do you
that
in the administrative rules for the
parole board there are multiple factors
that are
um
that are reviewed when it comes to
showing remorse showing accountability
for your actions Obviously good behavior
while you're in incarcerated to to an
extent we have some guidelines around
disciplinary fractions
um
what what what is your plan moving
forward how do you present yourself in
the parole hearing itself
um you know like you said you know you
show accountability for your actions
right do you show remorse there are many
people that are
um they deny their crime or they are
diverting blame and stuff like that and
that shows that somebody's not really
ready to be released
um
in in the cases of like Mr Pineda I I
actually remember his name I believe I
was in classifications when he was there
and I remember an officer actually
saying this person needs to be granted
parole like this is the type of person
that is like when you look at sports
individuals and you say you ask is this
person a Hall of Famer if you cannot say
right off the top yes they're all a
Famer and they might not be a Hall of
Famer kind of goes the same way for some
people on parole it's like that person
should be granted parole they've done
everything to change their life you know
there are some people who
can fake it till they make it and it's
unfortunate but those people do get by
most of the time the parole board you
know asks a lot of tough questions
during the hearings to find those
individuals and and make sure that they
are indeed ready the pro board cannot
arbitrarily deny anyone we have to have
a reason we have to set
um
conditions of what they need to do to
come back in front of us once they once
thank you Mr chairman um what would you
say there's been people and if so how
many who have been released or given
parole who under your definition
wouldn't be rehabilitated
that wouldn't be rehabilitated I'm kind
of hoping none but
um
and also like I had said about people
that can fake it till they make it they
present really well and and I mean we
have the case of I don't know how many
people know their name but Brian
shervalley he's I believe the reason
there was a parole board in 2019 he was
released he was down at the halfway
house so as a classifications
administrator I knew he did all of the
program he needed to do to make his way
down into Community Corrections and then
was released on parole and couple months
after he was released on parole he
murdered somebody in Massachusetts
so and then he blamed the parole board
for releasing him that he should have
never been released but all the
documentation and the presentation of
him at the parole board
showed that he had done everything that
he should have done and to rehabilitate
himself and and to be released
we certainly look at the mandatory
toward programs that they are supposed
to complete those that the court
required and also we look at programs
that they voluntarily did
uh but uh actually I've been impressed
with the number of programs I have I
certainly wish that they could have more
as has been uh mentioned earlier uh but
there's only so much staff and so much
good afternoon I'm sitting here before
you as part of the National Council for
incarcerated and formerly incarcerated
women but also as a formerly
incarcerated woman myself and so in
listening to a lot of important
discussion that's been going on I've
kind of scrapped everything that I
thought I was going to say and trying to
respond to things that were have been
said today
so I just want to I'm sorry if it's
disjointed for that reason who's been
privacy taking notes someone had
mentioned that that when you go when you
commit a transgression you have a chance
to go and the judge hears both sides in
the in the experience of myself or other
women that I have been incarcerated with
that was not the case because the
majority of the women took plea deals in
which they didn't have the chance to
speak for their side out of fear for a
more lengthy sentence
um I think it's important to remember
that the the women and I'll speak for
the women because I was incarcerated
with them and I am a woman who is
incarcerated only Lee a lot of a lot of
them are victims themselves right so
we're talking about I'm not justifying
any time that they may have caused harm
to other people but in listening to
their stories and learning about who
they are as human beings the amount of
trauma that most of them have endured
has been heartbreaking
um with unspeakable things that they've
had to go through
marginalization poverty extreme abuse
and neglect doesn't justify their
behavior later on as an adult but a lot
of them are ill-equipped and haven't had
the necessary guidance so I just like to
remember that piece and it helped me to
learn more about them as as human beings
and for myself to be humanized in spite
of my mistakes
I do want to um somebody had mentioned I
think representative wheeler you had
asked a great question about how do we
address
um the point for people who have been
victimized so that they're not feeling
like they didn't have the healing and
I'm sorry if I'm getting your question
and correct but I thought about the fact
that um I've been victimized and
assaulted when I was a child and what I
was missing was the reparation the
chance for me to get that acknowledgment
and validation from the person who
harmed me I think initially my my gut
reaction as a young child who was harmed
would have been like yes please punish
him let him suffer like I did but when I
really think about it and now as I sit
here before you as a mother of three
children what I want is that opportunity
to send out even at this day as an adult
woman sit down and say this is how you
impacted me and I just need you to know
that and let that kind of reparation
occur so I'm hoping that answers your
question as a previous victim victimized
person and I do want to personalize
right now down the road about a few
miles is the both men and women's prison
and there are some women in there who
are sitting there as we speak
um and I do want to just bring their
name um their first name to your
attention in a situation that they're in
for example Nicole sentenced when she
was 17 years old she's now in her 30s
and she was she's been sentenced to a
quote violent crime but yet in her
presence I've never seen her be violent
in any kind of way shape or form she is
actually a model resident in which she
participates and takes advantage of
everything gets minimal write-ups
um you know just seems like a normal
human being when you're just talking in
conversation with her and she's handled
herself now all these years she's grown
up in prison and she's tried every
Avenue to get out of prison
um you know we've talked about all these
ways your two-thirds earned time credit
getting your judge to reduce your
sentence and none of them have been
proven effective yes you she earned the
21 month off over many many years of
time but that's nothing when you talk
about the amount of her life that she's
missed she she likely will not be able
to bear or have her own children because
she will have been incarcerated that
entire time she is arguably
institutionalized right when you talk to
women who are released after a long
period of time another woman Angie in
Massachusetts I just she was just
released after 33 I think 30 years being
in prison she's scared to go to her own
appointments and needs her children to
drive her there doesn't know how to use
a cell phone I mean you think about how
fast technology Moves In keeping up with
that and coming out into the community
when things have changed in so much time
how you know I'm just trying to imagine
what is that like to survive after Ben
you know you've been inside for so long
there's a woman named Sam Who's down the
road right now she's been incarcerated
for 33 years she is an old woman now in
her 70s she can and not really breathe
well she needs a machine sometimes to
breathe she can't have a a cell on the
second floor because she can't go up and
down stairs she too has accessed
everything to try to redeem herself and
is the sweetest old woman you would ever
meet like I would want her as my own
grandmother she is highly involved in
faith Services she is a mentor to other
women she sits down on her own accord
and has private Bible studies with them
she too and her family has tried many
many times in many different ways to get
her out and yet she's afraid that she
may die in prison
and you know again I I would allow her
to be around my children like I've spent
time with her and had conversation with
her
um
so I hope that in painting this picture
I just you know I'm sitting here and
listening and we're all these people
making decisions about other people and
I wanted to represent that voice today
right people who make mistakes people
who are
um you know sorry and and trying to
redeem themselves in some way and
everybody deserves a chance at
Redemption so thank you for hearing me
thank you for your your testimony and
you certainly uh spoke from the heart
and I I just have one question for you
if I may
um under the under the bill that we're
here hearing testimony on would would
this have made you been eligible for
Pearl sooner this bill would not have
applied to me so I'm speaking when I'm
speaking I'm I'm thinking of all the
women that it could have applied to or
even the women the women that it would
not have applied to and it should have
thank you for their representative Noel
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for taking
my question
um and thank you so much for coming here
and and representing truly The Human
Side of of this right and um I think
we've heard a lot about the things that
are taken into consideration different
programs different ways that you can
kind of demonstrate
um that you have been rehabilitated in
some way and I'm wondering you know you
what you've brought here today I think
is really
um the trauma of you know humanizing
um what goes into someone taking an
action that may put them behind bars
right I mean um lead to incarcer
representative could you please ask your
question
and so my question is how do you see
that factoring in to
um the things that have been
demonstrated uh yeah
that's you get my question yes I do
um I think that uh we're all human right
and I would argue that almost
everybody's sitting in the prison both
men and women or even in the jails today
have endured a lot
um and and haven't necessarily had the
supports right there's so many people
who don't have anybody to call home to
on the weekends or don't have anybody to
put money on their books um and actually
could just side note going back to
Nicole she was just told recently that
she needed five thousand dollars to pay
for a lawyer just a retainer fee to try
to pursue another Avenue out of prison
and she you know makes a dollar a day
and so just how defeating that would be
um anyway side note back to your
question yeah I think that myself
included and all of these people have a
significant amount of trauma and at the
end of the day you know it's
embarrassing and it's we have a lot of
Shame around making mistakes and being
put in the public eye and being
scrutinized and I can't speak for
everybody but you know I want a chance
at Redemption I want a chance you know
to not sit behind bars and be away from
my family I mean the time that I spent
away from my children was the most
excruciating curl you into a ball pain
that I can ever explain to you there
aren't enough words for it and in fact
listening to the pain of my own children
being separated from me
um is so painful it's hard to hear it's
actually
hard to even look at pictures
um of the time while I was away so to
cut a sentence in half by 50 it's not an
automatic it's not a given you're still
trying to earn it right and you still
have to sit before a parole board and in
many ways relive your your sentencing in
some ways right you have to defend
yourself again you have to relive you
know what you did wrong and I'm I don't
want to excuse wrongdoing I want to be
very clear about that but it is a human
process right we're all human beings and
at the end of the day and I as a mother
I don't want our streets to be unsafe I
don't want them to be unsafe and yet I
can also look at the human component of
this and say that I'm quite sure that
prison is not healing anybody or making
our streets safer in the long term it
might put a Band-Aid on it because
they're unavailable or in a Cell but at
some point most people are returning
back to the street and we want them to
have be a better stronger wiser are a
more well-adjusted person and and what I
see happening in the prisons what I've
thank you thanks for taking my question
um so you've been speaking to you've
been telling stories of people who I
suppose you would characterize as
rehabilitated which is the purpose of
imprisonment according to the state
constitution
um
so I was wondering if you could speak to
how you feel if this applies how you
feel that their continued imprisonment
at the point past the point where
they're
arguably rehabilitated has affected
their ability to maintain that state
um and if it plays any role in maybe
sliding backwards or as you mentioned a
moment ago feeling defeated anything
along those lines
yeah I think when you when you said
um alone in a Cell for hours upon end
and you know during covid there were
people locked down for as long as like
43 days that does something to your mind
that's not even speaking to people who
are who get you know put in the
quote-unquote whole where you know you
hear them screaming out loud or women
who end up in like a bit of a psychosis
because I witnessed a woman who was in a
padded room for weeks with no sunlight
and no fresh air where she was
unclothing herself and writing messages
on the walls with her feces and her
Menses saying help me get me out of here
and so yeah I do think that long-term
incarceration does something to the
human brain I'm not a scientist in that
way
um but I do think that it's possible to
regress in some of the progress that you
might make I I don't know it's probably
an individual basis right everyone has a
different makeup a different resiliency
a different level of um you know wanting
to do better when I'm looking at these
women that I mentioned to you you know I
mean luckily Sam is very spiritual so
she prays a lot and she just hopes that
it's going to work out in in God's
timing I think Nicole just is Relentless
and strong and doesn't give up so she's
going to keep fighting but you get these
setbacks and you go in your cell and you
thank you for your testimony thank you
is this on
thank you members of the kid committee
my name is Joseph lascaz I will be
representing the ACLU of New Hampshire
in support of this bill I will also be
representing myself in a formerly as a
formerly incarcerated individual of the
New Hampshire Department of Corrections
um in in support of this I will also be
speaking from the perspective of the
individual who mentors both adults and
juveniles that are Justice involved in
the community from that perspective as
well
uh three years ago what at the start of
this bill I've been working on this uh
for uh for this bill for three years
because there is an issue that is going
on at the Department of Corrections when
it comes to individuals being able to
apply for early release who are ready
and deserve it as opposed to who can get
it
so the first the first argument that I
would like to make involving earn time
credit and why this differs from that
and why it's needed is earn time credit
is not Behavior based we heard we heard
testimony that an individual can fake it
to they make it
under this provision that would not be
done because you cannot fake the
criteria that are outlined in this bill
that is something that you have to do on
a daily basis as opposed to being able
to just sign up for something or fake it
as as in what we heard
when truth and sentences was introduced
to New Hampshire in the 80s there was
only 394 people that were currently
incarcerated it took over 170 years to
reach that number and as soon as truth
and sentence was incarcerated over the
next 37 years that number quad drupled
to over 2 000 where we are still
hovering around the numbers have gone
down but we are hovering around the
numbers after the explosion of Truth and
sentencing multiple states have already
repealed truth and sentencing and
statistically their crime rate has not
increased
we heard some testimony about the
individuals who would be released under
truth and sentencing and if these are
I myself was formerly incarcerated on
violent charges of armed robbery things
that I am not proud of I was 17 years
old I made very poor choices
I spent my time I did I did my time I
made different choices during that
incarceration and I was released since
then I work in court diversion programs
for juveniles where I keep them out of
the system by working with Manchester
juvenile probation parole major police
athletically where we Mentor these kids
where we use our experiences to show
them a different path this was
recognized to the point where even where
a New Hampshire judge has released an
individual to the supervision of the
program that I oversee because they saw
a better benefit to a person who was
rehabilitated using their experience to
combat Street violence and gang gang and
entering into gangs than to keep them
locked in a Cell where they're just
rotting away
there is such a low percentage of
individuals who go up for their 65120
that this provision right here sort of
evens the playing field and this is not
a census modification this does not
apply to the sentencing part of law this
only applies to the parole eligibility
of the parole eligibility part of the
law which the parole board it is their
duty to deem an individual as safe and
rehabilitated as we just heard if the
parole board was was releasing
individuals who were not rehabilitated
or safe then they would be held liable
for the actions of individuals once they
are released and that's not the case so
there's a reason why we have that in
place and this provision only puts
people in front of them with an
opportunity for them to make an
assessment of whether or not they're
ready I just wanted to talk about why
this was put to why the amendment said
seven and a half years on on page one or
page two I guess uh uh line six uh uh
subpart a the person was sentenced to a
minimum of not less than five years
currently the the average minimum
sentence that an individual gets at the
Department of Correction is three and a
half years that is without this
provision they get a minimum three and a
half years that's the average sentence
so
after working with the Department of
Corrections and other stakeholders on
this provision we came to the conclusion
that five years was not enough time for
an individual to be able to complete all
court ordered programs doc required
programs as well as get ready to to form
their transition back into society so
that number was put up to seven and a
half years which if they even did fit
the criterias of that were outlined in
the bill and the parole board did decide
to grant them they still would be doing
the average amount of time that an
individual currently is sentenced to the
Department of Corrections
the person has no major or a-level
disciplinary violation an a-level
offenses attempted Escape assault on a
correctional officer institutional
murder rape drug dealing inside for
those are the type of offenses that are
categorically restricted from being able
to parole from under hip
the retroactive portion of this was
something that was taken out because
what we wanted to do was take into
concerns that take into account the
concerns of every individual including
those of the victims who did not want to
have to be re-victimized by going back
to court so the retroactive portion
would be taken out and what that would
do is it would be something that would
be going forward as in the earn time
credits and the 65120 that people are
aware of when they apply for parole
in closing I just want to say that many
individuals in this Committee in this
room they know me they know the changes
that I've made they know the things that
I'm doing in this in in the state for
the benefit
if that is not deemed to be a value or
of a benefit to the community if the
individuals I ask you come with me on a
Wednesday night to Manchester and see
the difference that the individuals with
lived experience are making in the in in
youth to stop future victimization to
start future problems the criteria that
are outlined in this bill are the
criteria that if someone makes that that
is someone who deserves to be back in
the the community we sentence people to
a Department of Corrections not a
department of punishment because there
is a difference we are trying to correct
the behavior of individuals who are
coming back home and the way to do that
is to incentivize that on a daily basis
happy to take any and all questions that
I
I just want to pose the same question to
you that I asked of the last speaker
about
um
if when you were incarcerated or in your
time since leaving
um if you've observed any instances in
which someone was affected detrimentally
by continuing to be incarcerated after
they were probably
um
rehabilitated
let me think of one that did so there
was an individual in New Hampshire he
was an 18 year old he was an 18 year old
kid
never once ever been arrested in his
life he was the first person in his
entire family to be arrested his mother
is the CEO of a Fortune 500 company out
of Canada
he was driving with his friends on a
highway they were all going to uh they
were going out to eat and they were dry
he was driving and just young kid he he
missed his exit so he tried to pull a
move on the highway to get on to the
next one hit a person
um and he wasn't Under the Influence or
anything he just made a poor judgment
call the person and losing delay he was
sentenced uh he he was sentenced to a
manslaughter charge where he got a
15-year sentence
and this kid from the day that he came
in you could tell that this person was
nasty he
he committed an offense and what he did
was wrong and horrible but a prison
environment was not the environment for
this kid because within months of him
being there he was he had no Direction
no guidance was scared
and after time got swallowed up into the
criminalized mentality
um that that goes on in that environment
he came in uh
on the straight and narrow and when I
left was already being recruited by
gangs was already getting high in prison
was holding on to drugs and that story
happens all the time I
the first five years of my bid I was not
who I am right now in this room if I had
been if if I had the opportunity the
first time uh you know maybe things
would have been different I can't I
don't know but what ends up happening is
when a person hits a certain point where
they are no longer actively engaging in
criminal Behavior so they have now made
a choice like I am like this is not the
lifestyle I want
when you have to sit in an environment
where everything else is going that
opposite direction where you are treated
as if you are going in that opposite
direction that can break down also it
makes you a magnet because you are no
longer the same as everyone else prison
as a predator or prey environment that's
it simple and plain and when a person
chooses that they are no longer going to
do that other people will then start to
try to victimize that person because
they're like why aren't you doing the
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chair and I'll try to be as quick as I
can
um what is the difference in your view
as someone who has had first-hand
experience with this between the law as
it would be in HB 58 if it was passed
and the current early release programs
that are in the Department of
Corrections
that's a great question um
representative wheeler so the other
programs that are currently in the
Department of Corrections that
um allow for early release they do not
apply to everyone categorically so for
instance uh they St that you can get up
to 21 months if you do college classes
not everyone has the economic means of
taking college classes
some of the some of the earn time credit
uh there's their specific criteria for
applying for earn time credit and so for
instance the family connection center
offers a program when I was incarcerated
I couldn't do the family connection
program because I don't have kids
the mental health department offers
programs that individuals could do that
to get earn time credit when I went and
got a mental health assessment they said
I did not have a mental health problem
so I could not do the mental health
classes
I already went to prison with a high
school diploma which meant that I could
not get their own time credit from doing
a high school diploma class or I mean
high school credit class or the high set
class which meant that the only way that
I could get earned time credit was
paying for a college degree and that
does not seem like earning it that seems
like buying it
this provision in HP 588 what this does
is this is on a daily basis from the
moment you wake up to when you go to
sleep each day you have to behave a
specific way which in my opinion as a
person who was formerly encouraged and
gone through this that is the only way
to form the habits that we're looking
for for people to make right judgments
right it's from habit the reason why you
can tie your shoes
blindfolded is because you've done it so
many times it becomes a habit that's
what we're looking to do we're trying to
make people we're trying to establish
individuals making healthy choices where
it is a habit where it becomes easy to
make the right choice I know that we're
like why are we rewarding people for
making the right choice no the
individuals that are eligible for this
did not make a right choice to begin
with so that means they did not think
the way that we are trying to get them
to think which comes from repetitious
Behavior
that's outlined in this bill
thank you for your testimony today
does anyone else who hasn't testified
wishing to testify
there being none here by closest public
hearing
and I hereby open the public hearing on
HB
which one's next
.
that's
right yeah
representative Jones please uh introduce
your bill
thank you
that's a very uh solemn subject to
follow up on but thank you for having me
Mr chairman and representatives
my name is Philip Jones
I am the house representative for
Cheshire District 3 which is Keen Ward
5.
I'm here today uh to introduce House
Bill 158
uh there there is a handout
that is
an amendment
which I can't do that's becomes once it
gets an HP number you uh it's up to the
committee to make any amendments it's a
very short Amendment it's one sentence
that uh that I admitted that says
those who are exempt from this bill and
that would be all police agencies being
local County and State
when you're acting in their official
Duty
going back many years
in 1980s
I was a Town Council there
for nine years it's a different style of
government
I was the called the police liaison
which came to the title of police
commissioner
back in those days
we didn't have productive vests for our
police officers
I and a couple other people went out and
raised money and we raised over sixty
thousand dollars so our police force it
was a small Force Under 30. could
all be protected before that time they
were buying uh
old army flak jackets and so on and that
was the term used back then flak jackets
um so I did
three three-year terms in New Jersey and
you know what it's time for me to move
to nice New Hampshire uh before I left I
want to thank the police from New Jersey
they awarded me
the gold excuse me the silver honorary
lifetime
patrolman's benevolent Association badge
which I carry in my pocket to this day
because I'm very proud of it
that I was honored that way
moving fast forward
I'm glad to be living in Keene New
Hampshire I was glad to be out of
politics
that being said
I'm in my 27th year on the city council
in once again overseeing the police
overseeing the police which was part of
our job as City councilor some of our
viewers I know are also serving in
different communities
and it's your job to look over the
police
I know in Keene I had uh about 10 years
ago I had introduced legislation
that we paint the blue line down the
middle of the street that the street
that our Keene police station is on so
every day when those police officers
those men and women of our Police
Department come to work it's a reminder
that our city is behind them the people
are behind them we honor we honor you we
right now Keen is the only city in New
Hampshire it's something that started as
a school project in Oklahoma Oklahoma
cities are doing it in New Hampshire New
Jersey cities are doing it and Ohio
to my bill
it's a simple my bill is a simple
Amendment
to RSA
159 18.
it uses the same definition
of the ammunition I didn't want to make
it very complex
all at the old Bill
159 18
it being a criminal issue if
armor-piercing ammunition was used
in the committing of a crime a
misdemeanor felony it was considered to
be a misdemeanor for that
I simply changed the language
to say that
the same ammo using the same definition
that you had
prohibits owning storing purchasing
selling Distributing manufacturing and
custom making
of any ATM ammunition designed and
intended that's the important part
designed and intended to penetrate armor
plating or ballistic vests
and that's where I'm going with that I'm
all it's all about safety uh that's
always been my mantra
representative Rhodes you uh came before
my Transportation committee with a
safety issue I immediately uh
woke up to that and said that's a good
one and uh I'm glad I'm glad you brought
now
I think one of you are about to ask
uh what other states have
this kind of
statutes it's uh Alabama California
Connecticut DC Florida
all of them have
all of them have statutes they're all
very complex
the one I wrote is much more user
friendly
I can want to say audience because I'm
used to the city
um keep one in California statute
because that was a reactive statue in
Palm Springs California
it was a perpetrator
who sat in his house called the police
through his house because he said he had
an emergency when they got there
he shot through the door
these these three police officers were
wearing protective vests he shot through
the door
killing two police officers and injuring
another
which is one of the reasons why I'm not
sure why we need these vests
um
and so you ask what is the federal law
the federal law
about this this people 18 or over can
buy shotgun or rifle ammunition only
all other ammunition can be
can be sold only to people 21 or over
uh so
in the eyes of the federal people there
has to be some protection also otherwise
they would have let 18 year olds buy
that same ammunition
we're all familiar with some of the
recent shootings
the uh school shooting in Texas
I believe 17 children and two
the perpetrator there
he bought he went out and bought
over 5000 rounds of ammunition from a
when that incident happened it took a
couple days
for them to identify the bodies because
he used such ammunition and they had to
do DNA because they were picking up arms
and heads and legs from all over the
place and they had them match them up
with the Torso because that's what this
ammunition does and that's what I'm
the most horrendous shooting incident
ever happened in the U.S was in Las
Vegas where the perpetrator and I'm
being nice calling him a perpetrator
he bought over 60 000 rounds of
armor-piercing ammo
and an Arizona gun show
so he bought that and no flags were
raised
I'd call this to protect our police bill
because I'm worried about our police I
think they need our protection I think
every one of you should be able to go
home and tell your local police
department I want to protect you
Banks and retailers are all now starting
to put in bulletproof partitions because
they want to protect
their employees
I think it's up to us to pass this bill
and help them protect your employees
School design Architects are now being
very creative
they're creating protective enclosures
that go in the back of a classroom maybe
maybe the size of 12 by 10
. uh they're being very creative they're
making a mean to either a code closet or
and it's a place for students to go and
hide if they need to once again
it's bulletproof but it wouldn't be
foreign
I'm very much open to questions I just
want to make it clear that
because there's been I know you've all
received a lot of emails this is not
about a gun bill at all I'm not changing
trying to control guns or change guns
this is about safety police safety
children safety worker safety and that's
what I'm all about
and I'll gladly answer any questions if
the committee has any Mr chairman thank
you
um
could you tell me specifically what
ammunition that I could purchase today
any anything it's a generalized
definition anything that's designed or
intended
to uh Pierce body performer
bulletproof farmer excuse me no yeah I
got that I was reading that thank you I
meant specifically like um a caliber a
brand not a caliber uh some of the other
states that have statutes do go into
that
and I'm trying to keep it very
generalized some of them say uh how much
tungsten carbide could be part of the
core because that's an important part of
I don't have a direct answer for you but
the generalized answer is anything
designed or intended to pierce armor
okay all right thank you
foreign
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative what
would be the procedure if a person
well
it says it takes effect January 1st 2024
I think there would probably be a phase
out like uh we do with dangerous
chemicals we never uh I'm in the
chemical sales industry so I know a lot
about that
um
and when we
when we find toxic chemicals we we
and I don't know if I'm answering your
question uh that could be something the
committee could add to it
a phase-out portion
because that's a good question that I
representative Manny
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question my question is about
the amendment to it state county and
municipal office will be exempt in the
course of their official duties I know a
lot of state troopers and Deputy
sheriffs would take their cruises home
they're trained with this ammunition
they would not be able to defend
themselves because they would not be
able to take that ammunition home with
them is that the way I understand that
correctly
no they would have to keep it locked up
and it would be available for use if
they were using it for official use but
if it's locked up at their house they
could not possess it according to this
bill
that's a good question uh
there there would have to be some kind
of lock up
position that would be determined by the
by the state authorities
thank you for your testimony all right
um
just letting the public know we have a
whole stack of of testimony here
um I hope that while while you get ready
to testify you take into account what we
just heard and
um
the first person I'm going to recognize
is
thank you Mr chair thank you to the
committee for hearing my testimony today
um I've received more than a few emails
on this particular bill
they're not generally happy emails
they're not pleased with it
I think I should start with my
background a little bit I have a
background in competitive shooting as a
range safety officer
I hand load ammunition and I've been
through the ATF process for
manufacturing Small Arms ammunition so I
know a little bit about what's going on
here
let me tell you the way that this bill
is written
first of all part of it is duplicative
of federal law federal law already bans
armor-piercing ammunition there are
specific processes you can go through to
make an ammunition armor piercing such
as Teflon coating it
that's prohibited but the I would almost
say nefarious thing about this bill is
that it actually goes in a very
different direction
the very generalized language of this
bill suggests that any round that can
Pierce any body armor would be a felony
so let me explain how this works
most police officers were running around
are wearing either level 2A or level 2
body armor that soft body armor that can
be penetrated by Handgun Ammunition in
excess of nine millimeter and all rifle
ammunition
sorry bear with me
just just so you know before you get too
far into it
um the committee has um three four Law
Enforcement Officers so yes so we we're
kind of aware of a lot of stuff so sure
um just to finish that thought you can
accelerate a 22 caliber bullet out of a
regular hunting rifle with a 20 inch
barrel achieving nearly 4 000 feet per
second and that will defeat typically
level three and four steel body armor
so what we've established here is the
way this bill is written would make it a
felony to possess every rifle ammunition
and mini handgun ammunitions
so let's talk now a little bit about the
uh the ethical side of this this
committee has one of the most solemn
duties in the entire legislature you all
are responsible for deciding who gets
locked in a cage
that's a very serious thing we have a
tradition in this country of making sure
only dangerous people who are a threat
who have committed harms against Society
get locked up in a cage this bill
would lock my constituents in a cage it
would lock my neighbors in a cage and it
would lock me in a cage
that's a very very serious thing we're
um
sorry I lost my thought there
this is again this is a very serious
issue we have to treat it with a
seriousness it deserves the last point
I'm going to make is that this actually
refers to the one and only piece of
property that is mentioned by name in
our constitutions armaments
that is the only piece of property named
by in individually in the whole
Constitution
and we have all sworn a duty to uphold
and defend that document
and I hope that you will all join me in
strictly being against this Bill thank
you very much I'm happy to take
questions
I just haven't I I don't have the
Constitution memorized so I'm just
wondering where I believe you said
Armament is that what you said is well
that would be the extended version of
thank you for your testimony thank you
I'll never get it right so
thank you Mr chair trust me I started
standing up when I saw you wondering how
to pronounce the last name I'm aware say
it for me please how do you say it I
said Popovich Miller but I promise not
to come here so often that you need to
really remember it
um and honestly
I was playing this was my day off I'm on
the finance committee this is a rare day
off for me the only reason I drove to
Concord is to speak against this
legislation I just could not in good
conscious stay home and not talk to the
committee about it
it's only three lines of legislation and
it has the highest density of legal
concerns that I've ever seen in
legislation first and I'll try not to
belabor points that were already covered
it is so vague I cannot comply with it I
have no idea what's covered previous
speaker already covered some of the
details I'm not gonna repeat it but I
will just say that any law that is so
vague that a regular citizen does not
know how to follow it should not be ever
passed
you know or else we will all be guilty
and whoever goes to jail will be
determined by the mood of you know
whatever law enforcement is charging
people is arresting people
it was already covered that not only
there is no definition of what the ammo
is but there is no definition of armor
in the law it just says armor what is
armor I mean if you make that definition
you know unclear any
ammo of any kind could become subject to
this ban
which means this is a ban of firearms a
firearm that does not have ammo that you
can use is a club and a particularly
useless Club because frankly the grips
are terrible for using it that way so
absolutely this is a ban out firearms
and by the way I mean no way implying
that was the intent of the legislation
I'm just telling you what the outcome of
also because it bans ammo that is in use
legal use common use for legal purposes
by a large percentage of our population
this is anti-constitutional in space you
know that if we pass it it will end up
challenged in courts and being struck as
anti-constitutional no point in going
through the exercise even if it passed
the only outcome of adding this
paragraph to our rsas would be to put
innocent people into jail not one
criminal will be convicted because of
this law that's already covered in the
two first two paragraphs that RSA
section it covers the people to commit
that commit crimes this legislation will
only be used to convict innocence people
who cross the law that they didn't
realize they were violating or they
didn't think was worth following and by
the way civil disobedience is a thing
but they never committed any crime they
were planning to shoot targets to to do
other things with the darn ammo we
shouldn't put those people in jail any
law that doesn't require anybody to be
harmed for people to go to jail is a
very tough law to defend I mean I looked
up at the New England Northern New
England Poison Control Center and they
list 29 poisonous plants that grow
commonly all around the New Hampshire
and 13 indoor plants that are poisonous
should those people who may be unaware
the darn things are poisonous or never
intend to use them to poison people be
sent to jail for possessing poison I
mean they possess poison
I'll conclude by saying that I'm a
freshman legislature I do my best to
work across the aisle
my two bills are bipartisan every bee
life co-sponsored the bills that I
co-sponsored range from all the other
co-sponsors being Republican to all the
other co-sponsors being Republic
Democrat
I genuinely just try to do the right
thing every time with disregard for
ideology and what party we are from and
I urge the committee to do the right
thing and you know send this bill to the
house with a near unanimous uh itl
recommendation please because
this is not something we should be doing
we have way better things to spend our
time and I really appreciate your time
so I'll finish here thank you
thank you
chair recognized
representative oh no excuse me um Aubrey
Freeman
Mr chair committee members Aubry
Friedman Bridgewater private citizen
um
I speak definitely in opposition to this
bill
um this bill just owning and storing
this kind of I'm ammunition like has
already been said you would already be
and I'm wondering which was not answered
by the
sponsor was how it seems like you could
you could literally
um with a warrant mind you uh go to
everybody's home you know look at a list
of anybody who bought a rifle and they
probably have this kind of ammunition
literally
start arresting people so this is this
is just a disaster uh for uh Second
Amendment and a private uh you know plus
also what's interesting too uh just
adding that part about a police being
exempt but as I see it when it comes to
the Second Amendment the population
should be have the same capability
abilities to protect themselves as as
the government and so law enforcement
can have this kind of ammunition but not
the general public that's a disaster I
want the general public individual
citizens to have at least the same
amount of uh protection against tyranny
um and uh
well that's about it
um thank you uh any any questions
chair recognizes James Griffin
the Thunder Gap
thanks for your time I'm sorry that
we're all doing this today
um I think it's been made clear that the
bill is is poorly written
it if you read it it speaks to to armor
plating well
we've had definitions for different
levels of armor for for decades nij list
two was it 2A or two plus three three a
level four rifle plates and it fails to
Define it so so does this apply what
what is an armor plating is that like a
medieval you know breastplate I mean
the effect
of this bill will Define any and all
ammunition as armor piercing
all hunting ammunition will be armor
piercing
all self-defense ammo will be armor
piercing it it's an ill couldn't see of
Bill I haven't seen anything this bad
since Jeannie deach's range closer act
in 2020. the unintended or intended
consequences of this are horrific
uh
I'm sorry to be so harsh about this but
I expect better from from proposed bills
than this they should be better
considered and better thought out than
this
and so I'm sorry to be harsh but we're
talking about a constitutional right
and and I anticipate or I hope that
everybody on this committee will take
that under consideration and uphold
their duty to defend and protect our
constitutional rights
um
thank you very much I'll entertain any
questions you may have
otherwise thank you for your time
thank you very much
I'm a little nervous so forgive me
um I applaud this bill I'm opposed to it
but I applaud it has good intentions
unfortunately it sounds like the
gentleman who put it Forward doesn't
have a whole lot of understanding of
ballistics and uh firearms in general
so everything I want to say has already
been said except that I want to add that
there's already a provision for Criminal
Intent in the bill that it would be
added to
there's no Criminal Intent at all people
could be found guilty with no Criminal
Intent
I could just see a zealous an
overzealous prosecutor
crucifying someone over this bill
I I
don't know what else to say it's it's I
applaud the bill but it's just not well
thought out by someone who's not
familiar with firearms and I believe I
don't believe that anybody wants to put
innocent people in in prison I heard the
testimony of the parole stuff and that
broke my heart to hear some of the what
people go through that we never think of
so
thank you very much for allowing me to
speak thank you for coming in today
chair calls Andrew schneller
Schuler anything that sounds remotely
thank you for your time
um I am against the bill I am a recent
Grant seder I've been here almost two
years now and I came here for more
freedom
monetarily economics uh and Firearms as
well
um but there's been a lot of great
testimony so far but I but for my
experience as an engineer I just like to
add that you can also get non-firearms
that can Pierce armor like bow and
arrows the boat and you can Pierce armor
even without combustion without
explosion and so the idea of this bill
is just to ban all firearm ammunition in
the state of New Hampshire and I think
that would weaken New Hampshire from any
other potential
incursions from criminals that's all I
wanted to say thank you guys
thank you for your testimony
and and to committee members if you have
a question of a
um please act fast because I'm going to
um chair recognizes Paul
O'Connell
so
nice to see people coming here for
freedom
so everything that I am excuse me
everything that I want to say basically
is um Ben said
um I came here today because it's such a
vague Bill everybody brought it up and
um I think that
as a sportsman someone who's interested
in shooting sports hunting all of that I
belong to a number of different clubs I
do three gun we travel around
if this bill was signed excuse me I
don't know why I'm like so nervous but
if this bill was signed
this is what 34 clubs in New Hampshire
say 2 000 members per Club so
it would probably make somewhere around
60 to 70
um people in New Hampshire
felons
with the stroke of a pen because
we all have excuse me
we all have um you know it's so vague
all my hunting rounds would be
incorporated into this and at 70 years
old I'd be a felon so
um thank the committee for listening
um if you can't tell I'm nervous
and um please
don't pass this bill
good afternoon Mr chairman committee
members
my name is Kevin Williams and I am
against the bill and I'll give you a
little bit of my background I just
recently retired from 26 years of law
enforcement
um part of my job is in law enforcement
I spent 15 years as a senior Firearms
instructor for a federal agency
I'm a use of force instructor a active
shooter response instructor Close
Quarters battle instructor and I'm also
an EMT who has actively worked on the
ambulances here in New Hampshire
um
the bill extremely vague it would pretty
much
make almost all ammunition out there
illegal in the state of New Hampshire as
an officer wearing soft body armor
every rifle round would penetrate my
vest and that's something I had to deal
with every day but it's the nature of
the Beast you didn't need special
armor-piercing ammo to penetrate my body
armor
um
regular hunting rods would have
penetrated it
so having 26 years in law enforcement I
think this is a bill that is
a solution looking for a problem I don't
see it as a problem here in New
Hampshire
it's already illegal to use ammunition
to shoot somebody
so whether it's armor piercing or not
it's illegal to do that it's a crime
it's a felony already so why are we
trying to make more laws that are
already illegal I mean it's
um
you know and I I and I'm speaking as a
law enforcement a former law enforcement
officer who had a friend that was shot
and killed in the line of duty
that bill would not have saved him or
protected him at all
so uh I just don't think it's needed
thank you for your time if I I could
have just I'd like to use your expertise
just real quick I have a question based
on your your previous job as um
um the Firearms instructor and use of
force I did some research I couldn't
find any are you aware of a police
officer that's ever been killed with
armor-piercing ammunition no anywhere
no no I'm aware of finding okay thank
you and the ammo that we carried was a
62 grain soft point hunting round right
thank you thank you
sure absolutely one more question sir if
you don't mind
sorry I also just wanted to take
advantage of your expertise thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I was just wondering you know a
lot of people have brought up how vague
the definition is and this definition
the sponsor said was pulled from the
existing RSA do you think it would be
amenable to change the definition and
the RSA as it stands now
well
the the term that really concerns me is
designed
um who's to say what a round was
designed for
so you could take a 62 or 64 Grand 223
soft point round which people use for
hunting and it will penetrate a car door
and it would penetrate my soft body
armor but was it designed for that
you take 30 odd 6 ammunition designed by
the military uh back during World War
One and World War II uh well
predominantly World War one it was used
definitely would penetrate body armor uh
was it designed for body armor no they
didn't have body armor back then
um 308s used in World War II our guys
weren't running around with body armor
in World War II but yet a 308 will
penetrate body armor so who's to say
what Iran was designed for who's going
to determine what that round was
designed for and then intended who's
going to determine what my intended use
of that round was
and again it's already a felony for me
to use a projectile to shoot at somebody
so I just
I don't think there's uh any law needed
to
say that armor-piercing bullets are
illegal or should be illegal because
shooting at somebody is illegal period
thank you members of the committee uh
and thank you for listening to us all
today I know it's a very trying long day
for everyone so I appreciate it my name
is Joe Hannon I'm the vice president for
gun owners of New Hampshire
uh obviously we're in in opposition to
this bill uh I wasn't even sure what to
say at first when I read it because
where do I begin I mean there are so
many uh I I could just say it's a bad
Bill and just leave and probably just as
effective
um I'm I'm gonna just mention a couple
things and not at the 50 or 60 things
that I found
um
we keep hearing that the definition is
the same as the existing uh statute and
it's not exactly the same
uh the existing statute talks about
armor piercing exploding bullets and
cartridges the word ammunition has never
even mentioned and if you look at the
definition of ammunition most people
think of ammunition as a full round or
bullet cartridge well bullet is the tip
of the part that comes out the the part
that thing goes out after goes bang but
uh ammunition could also refer to the
case the primer the the accelerant any
part of that whole round or cartridge is
ammunition so manufacturing a custom
production of any firearm ammunition
that could be anything and it could be
just parts of the bullet so if someone
is making primers which is a little part
that the pin or Hammer hits to make it
go boom if they're producing primers and
they're selling some of them for you
know 20 little 22 Target or not 20
spring fire but if they're selling for
target practice or if they're selling
for armor piercing uranium you know
depleted rounds which I've never seen by
the way
um you know that's still the same thing
that could be that could be uh still a
felony to do that uh the example of the
the person in Las Vegas who sold the uh
the armor-piercing ammunition to the Las
Vegas shooter uh that person was
convicted they pled guilty and did Sir
and were sentenced to 13 months in
prison they were convicted for
manufacturing without a license they
weren't convicted for selling it or for
armor piercing they said they they
weren't even sure if it was armor
piercing during the trial the judge
ruled it was armor piercing but they
didn't prove that any of the bullets
came from him I'm not defending this
idiot for in any means but he admitted
he sold tracers which are just the the
bright things that come out you see a
machine gun in a movie and it shoots you
know one thing you can see and there's a
few bullets in between that's so that if
someone's shooting an automatic weapon
they can see where it's going
do are Tracer is coming out of this I
don't think they'd even be counted under
this the existing set the existing RSA
or the amendment
um or the the bill and and finally
um
you know the amendment that was proposed
and we haven't really seen yet exempting
Law Enforcement Officers I find that
most egregious that you know this is
such a heinous thing body parts can
explode apparently and all this stuff
but the cops can use it on us
I think that alone is one of the most
scary things I've heard in a long time
in this building and uh
I I just beg you to just get rid of this
as fast as you can and move on be more
important things to do thank you very
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I actually do have a fair
amount of things that have not been
addressed uh just by way of background
relevant to this hearing I've held a
federal firearms license for a few
months under 40 years
and
also
I'm an international economic consultant
so I tend to sort of look for data
I will do my best not to cover topics
already addressed
but in some the only possible aim of
this bill is to ensnare the law abiding
well let me put a sort of a face to that
I have in my pocket
little card
that I'll hold up and if you want me to
pass it around I will this is a
Massachusetts
non-resident license to carry firearms
this license or one that
its predecessor was wrongly revoked in
2009 it took three and a half years of
litigation and about a hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars before The
Supreme Judicial Court of Massachusetts
ordered this license to be restored to
me there were at no point any criminal
charges filed because I'd broken the law
here's my point laws such as this one
as everyone has pointed out vaguely
worded
can be used to entrap someone and here's
a principle the process is the
punishment
so even if the person proves that they
didn't break the law their meanwhile out
tens of thousands of dollars in the case
of this law
if it is alleged that someone used
armor-piercing ammo an expert has to be
hired
to say yes it was or no it wasn't that
expert five to ten thousand dollars per
day plus expenses
a lab has to be found to examine the
bullet
they're probably two or three such labs
in the entire United States
gotta think that's 10 grand
and all of those expenses are before
hundreds of hours of an attorney's time
so that even if the person's eventually
exonerated they're bankrupt for the most
part
so anyone who would write a law like
this
it's either negligent so gross as to be
breathtaking where there's
sir we we try to avoid um
casting
uh understood I'm just I just don't want
to assign any any um
intention to the sponsor I'm sure that
this committee will take take his uh his
word that it was for the protection of
law enforcement and we'll uh
go on from there
you've already heard that
most common ammunition will penetrate
vests
I will not
belabor that what I will tell you which
is new
that I can find no evidence that
armor-piercing ammunition has figured in
the death of any New Hampshire peace
officer
and I actually prepare on the third page
of my submitted testimony a list of
officers killed in line of duty from
1928 to 2014.
and I hope this list never grows
some of them sadly were shot in the head
a vest isn't relevant in armor isn't
relevant
some were shot through their vests
I give you enough detail so in short
the contingency
suggested by this bill is that
this is something that
perhaps has happened not in New
Hampshire
I didn't go back prior to 1928
because my best guess is and it's only a
guess
the armor the only armor-piercing ground
that might have existed prior to that
date is the 30 odd six round carried in
World War One
that round comes into from a military
point of view in two ways a standard
Lead Core and a steel core that is
hardened the steel core which is
normally in the military is the black
tip
so that it is known what it is
um standard ball ammunition has a plain
copper coating and for your background
for those of you who need it I explain
why military spec ammo consists of a
Lead Core and a thick copper foil jacket
it is to prevent
wounds that cannot be easily repaired
and that is under the 1899 Hague
convention so almost spec ammo
with rare exceptions
the other
set of data that I present to you is on
page four
it shows the incidence of violent crime
in the New England region all five
states
Virginia is there by the way because in
2015 the Virginians knocked us New
Hampshire people out of our position at
least since 2001 as the third safest
state in the Union we are now number two
the
for whatever reason or sets of reasons
we are not much given to doing
business violently
and I hope that Trend continues I wish I
had data for 2021 I don't
in short
this bill and any variant of it please
deem it in expedient to legislate
I have with me if anyone wants to see
two cartridges 762 by 39 which was the
round commonly used by Russia and
Eastern Bloc countries one of which has
a steel core it is not hardened but the
Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco firearms and
explosives deems it to be armor-piercing
I can possess that ammo
I can't sell it so if I want to go to
the range and expend it I am free to do
that
but there is no amount of money to be
found in this part of the Galaxy that
will tempt me to sell even a single
round
I have another round same chambering
the rounds look identical but it has a
Lead Core are we going to require police
officers to add to their Duty belts
hacksaws
so that if they can't saw through the
bullet well it must have a hardened
most officers I think will tell you we
have enough stuff on our duty belts we
don't want to have to carry a hacksaw
thank you and and we appreciate your
offer but we generally frown on Show and
Tell during Firearms days but thank you
for your testimony
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for your time
and if any of you have follow-up
questions my name and email are at the
bottom of my uh prepare testimony thank
you again you're welcome sir
um the chair recognizes Penny Dean
foreign
good afternoon whoops making sure it's
on good afternoon members of the
committee and thank you for hearing my
testimony I'm an attorney and I'm
licensed in Maine New Hampshire
Massachusetts admitted to all the
federal courts appropriate to those D.C
circuit
First Circuit Court of Appeals in the
United States Supreme Court and I'm
asking that you itl this bill it is
going to be void for vagueness on its
face I think if challenged the basic
reason is well there's many reasons but
the basic reason is
the sponsor said it's simple it's not
even close to simple
the term vest
and I've just given you some real basics
in my handout
when they talk about design to penetrate
armor plating or ballistic vests there's
a million different versions of
ballistic best and I won't belabor the
point but the gist of it is it's going
to matter if a vest is New Old what
grade most people have not tested vests
I have I've tested many vests at the
range with many different capabilities
and if you take some officers that wash
their vest if you wash your vest it
destroys the properties so those I'm not
sure the kids BB gun couldn't penetrate
so in short I won't belabor what
everyone else has said I'm happy to
answer questions but I passed out two
particular handouts that show there's
more than a dozen different standards
for best FBI uniform and the National
Institute of justice and those change I
didn't give out you the entire handout
for each one I gave you select Pages
because each one is about 100 pages and
most people other than the weird Geeks
like me don't want to read them and each
one of those has probably a thousand
pages of backup of government statistics
and so in short there's probably not a
round out there for rifles that wouldn't
be banned here
and it's just like Banning gasoline for
an internal combustion engine you could
have a million cars but if you can't get
any gasoline no point in having them
aware of the Democrats
thank you Mr chair members of Criminal
Justice representative Hull serving the
towns of Dunbarton
hoax hit Epson and Allenstown have to
think about it every time
here representing myself my constituents
as well as members of the New Hampshire
Firearms Coalition and a 501c4
non-profit that is
um
built up or is made up of people that
are both gun owners gun manufacturers
ammunition manufacturers and sporting
clubs within the state
um the bill before you
I'm I'm at a loss of words how egregious
it is
um
it seems simple
seems like this shouldn't be a problem
except we're going to turn almost all
the hunters in the state in the class B
felons and maybe maybe that was the
intent of the sponsors I don't I suspect
that wasn't the intent of the sponsors
but that's what it would do before you
is a box of hunting ammo
I wish I had more time to be in the
woods I missed spending my time with my
308 but this is 308 ammunition standard
hunting ammunition
has pictures of little animals on the
back right for use for Dangerous Game
and big game and medium game and even
environments representative just I don't
interrupt your flow there but please
leave it in the Box oh yes no I'm not
pulling it out I brought the box there
is rounds in it but um for the purpose
of having a conversation right this is
hunting ammo
this is routine 308 Winchester hunting
ammo use all the day in the woods
happens to have the same form and more
or less the same specifications as 761
by 52 millimeter
um NATO ammo
they're used interchangially in most
Firearms my point there is the the this
bill is drafted so poorly that you could
easily turn people into felons just
because they happen to have the wrong
ammo that interchangeably works with
their firearm
I would ask that you would IP this itl
this bill um there is no reason for us
to spend any more time on it it really
should just go away and
um
it was never about protecting the police
which is where I saw a bunch of Facebook
messages this was an attempt to band of
various a number of various forms of
ammo thank you
foreign
for the record I would I would like to
say that as far as this committee goes
we take the sponsor at his word and his
goal was to protect police officers
regardless of how you come down on the
bill itself and with that I will close
the public hearing
and the next public hearing is
hb503 I'm going to take a short uh seven
minute break bio break
who did
oh that lady that lady was up here with
all crying face lady she gave us a fake
name who found her
what's that what's her name
her name's not Katie University yeah she
thank you at this time I'm open to
public hearing on HP 503 and call the
sponsor to introduce bill
hmm
thank you chairman uh Dan Hines on
behalf of uh Bedford um Bedford and just
by way background because once when I
forget I am a criminal defense lawyer um
so I do know a lot about this issue and
so unfortunately this is a pretty broad
issue I am covering a lot of different
things what I'm attempting to do is
provide more rights to accused so some
of this is kind of codifying or making
more explicit things that sort of are in
case law so just by way of background so
the New Hampshire Constitution is my
opinion very very favorable to people
accused of a crime so Article 15 says
that everyone accused of a crime has all
proofs has the right to all proofs
favorable media as a defense lawyer
means everything that is in any form
exculpatory I should be given
um and generally speaking should be
admissible as evidence absent some other
I guess exception forsake a better word
so a lot of these things addressed here
would go to what I think is just
inherent in our system that if you're
going to accuse someone of crime and you
have evidence showing their innocence
that that person is entitled to that and
they're entitled to present that to
either the jury or the judge so I just
because it is a lot of different things
let's go through one by one what this
bill would do um so the first one is I'm
trying to get a speedy trial so while
there's a right to a speedy trial and
it's a constitutional right under the
Constitution the Federal Constitution I
think in my opinion it's absolutely
worthless in this state I've had very
few cases dismissed over more than a
decade on speedy trial grounds and in
every single one of those cases has
begun is because either the witness it's
basically because the state was unable
to proceed with the case because the
witness didn't show up I have a raised
speedy trial and many times always been
denied
um case law in this state is not good
um so offhand I believe like nine months
is sort of a triggering mark where
you're not even gonna be able to argue
it for misdemeanor cases prior to mine
months and in my experience when I've
argueded it after nine months the court
basically quickly said well they'll find
whatever reason it is not to dismiss
cases on a speedy trial and I understand
um we generally don't want cases
dismissed for Speed trial because a lot
of people who ultimately be found guilty
will be set free that way what I want to
do is actually give someone a speedy
trial so I was just reading the case in
the news I believe it was last month
where someone had to wait over three
years for a trial given as a murder case
but I still think three years and
there's nothing Speedy about three years
especially when you're being held
pre-trial on simple misdemeanor cases
um so pretty much mainly what I do is
DWI defense and so those are class B
misdemeanors meaning that someone can't
be sent to jail for it but if convicted
there is a mandatory license suspension
and
um just by way background I've suggest
that pretty much everyone who's charged
with a crime it's it's not just when
even when they're released that their
life just goes back to normal I mean
it's incredibly stressful to be waiting
not knowing worrying about the outcome
and everything that goes along with it
so getting back to what I was saying in
a lot of cases I'm not seeing trials in
District Court for even a year still
some course a lot better than others
there's certainly a problem and I know
Bell reform
um being
brought in from both this committee and
Judiciary one of the things that I see
people want out of bailware forum most
is the complaint that hey these people
are out on bail they're committing more
crimes I think the best solution to that
is short in the trial have people out on
bail less a shorter trial is just good
for everyone it's good for people who
are going to be found not guilty they'll
be set free and it's good for society if
someone's found guilty to have that
person punished in a timely fashion
rather than a year or more down the line
so I propose what I think is some
guideline or essentially what I think
would make a speedy trial I just picked
90 days I just picked that if the
committee feels it's more an appropriate
time for some other period frankly
anything is going to be better than what
we have now it's absolutely awful and I
think the main issue now of why trials
are just so long out just the lack of
resources so some courts are a lot
better but there's really not my opinion
a uniform speedy trial in this state so
part of what my bill did is increases
the penalty assessment uh which I tell
my clients is a fancy way of saying tax
so rather than legislature increase the
fines and all the cases this increased
penalty assessment which essentially
increases fines on all cases so
presently it's set to 24 uh when I first
started practicing law I was set to 20
so it does get increased occasionally
and I'm asking that it be increased
further with the intent that that money
is mainly going to judges and in
essentially
giving people the speedy trial that they
need and some of the other money is
being earmarked for the State Crime Lab
um which one of the things in my bill is
the preservation of evidence so what
happens in DWI cases if someone gives a
blood jaw is that blood is sent to the
crime lab the crime lab eventually
analyzes it and frankly this isn't at
the top of the list so it just depends
on how busy they are at the time but
routinely the lab does not give me
results Within a month so it's my
anticipation some of this money will
increase the lab to have them hire more
people
and the other problem is the lab does
not store blood in cases so specifically
a statute that says the lab can destroy
the blood after 30 days I'm never
getting a trial within 30 days so the
lab while they can destroy in 30 days
it's my experience they destroy it as
they're full so that could be six months
but it could be 30 days
so a lot of times especially if people
don't hire a lawyer right away by the
time they even hired me the blood's
already been destroyed I think it's just
outrageous that the state knowingly is
destroying evidence that they know is
going to be used in a criminal case
while that criminal case is pending they
know the case is pending they're it's
the state so
um I think if they were to do this for
DNA there'd be outrage but because it's
blood
um potentially it's alcohol used in DWI
case I guess people care less but at the
end of the day people have the right to
get that blood tested it sometimes comes
back different there could be issues
with it and just for basically the state
to destroy the blood because in my
opinion they can't afford to store it
which I can't imagine be very expensive
for a couple more refrigerators so this
is your marketing money for them for
that
um in regards to Discovery rights so New
Hampshire is generally pretty good we
have what's called an open file
Discovery so basically the prosecutor
will send you everything they have with
the exception of basically work product
so if the lawyer has opinions on the
case and Josh sat down they might not
send me that
um or witness I mean that but pretty
much everything else we get so this just
speeds up that time frame depositions
um so depositions in a criminal case is
a type of Discovery so basically is like
a interview that's being recorded with
someone under oath
um of a witness because the best mate
for me to describe that so I find it
interesting that you can get a
deposition in this case in this state a
lot easier in a civil case than you
criminal can in a criminal case I think
it's kind of backwards
um so I noted that the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
did submit um a I believe it did get
sent to me so I assume we got sent to
committee Nile forward to it uh the
committee it was an amendment um they
had better language for it so I'm just
um said it shall take place within 30
days but theirs went through uh
basically how it would take place and
they didn't have a Time requirement I
but I certainly would adopt their
amendment was a lot more thorough than
mine and they referenced putting in
chapter 5 17 13 so they also know they
didn't really have a preference if it
got put in this I also don't care if it
got put in that or this but I think
people should be entitled to that
positions with um the exception they
were looking for was miners I don't take
any issue with that
um
police honesty um I just believe peace
police should be honest with people when
they're interrogating people
um I think that's one of the main causes
of false confessions is lying to people
um write to Media I just believe that
people should have a right to
essentially
tell the media their side of the case
ahead of time
um presenting exculpatory evidence uh to
the grand jury I think if prosecutor
knows that there's evidence that shows
that someone did not commit a crime they
should be presenting that to a grand
jury and then the penalty assessment
like I said basically would increase the
final cases with the premise that it's
going to hire more judges and then money
earmarked related to alcohol cases with
the premise that the lab will then have
money to store evidence and actually
hire more analysts so that things get
analyzed in a quick ER fashion so it's a
rough summary of everything I know
there's a ton of stuff in here and
frankly if some of it got adopted some
is better than nothing so I would be
pretty supportive of pretty much any
Amendment keeping any of this and I'm
the chair recognizes uh attorney Andress
saves time
again my name is Jeff Sullivan
associated general from New Hampshire
Attorney General's office this is Steve
Anderson County Attorney's Office we
oppose this bill and I'll explain why so
I'm going to talk in general terms and
then we're happy to answer your
questions
sorry no you had it we just can't hear
you closer to you thank you you're
welcome uh so the bill is not necessary
and it's impractical those are the two
broad objections that we have pretty
much every aspect of this bill is
already covered by existing New
Hampshire law or court rules that
includes the issue of trial deadlines
speedy trial the discovery rights
depositions preservation of evidence and
grand jury proceedings those things are
covered in existing well-established New
Hampshire case law there's no need to
create laws that already duplicate those
and change them actually for the worse
because the standards this bill imposes
are quite frankly impractical given our
current system the deadlines in this
case could never be met with the number
of current lawyers we have our current
Staffing in the court you would have to
spend tens of millions of dollars to be
able to meet these deadlines it's simply
impossible given the amount of cases
that people currently have you have
prosecutors that have 150 to 200 cases
defense attorneys that have 80 to 100
cases in order to meet these deadlines
you would have to Triple quadruple the
number of those people and then have the
consummate same increase in core
Personnel that's simply not possible and
quite frankly it's not necessary most
every lawyer you talk to who does a
complicated criminal case will tell you
they want more time not less time that
murder case that was referenced is my
murder case
and it took three years to get the trial
because of covid and because the
defendant raised mental health issues
and insanity and those issues are
complicated and require multiple experts
and we did depositions and all those
things and that takes time so we wanted
to go to trial as quickly as possible
and the defense wanted more time and
that's typically how speedy trial works
sometimes it's the opposite but the
court balances those factors and in the
end the defendant has a right to
effective assistance of counsel and
unless an attorney only has one client
in one case they've got to balance the
needs of their other clients in other
cases and they want to take the time
that's necessary to do the best job for
their client and that's why we don't
have a speedy trial issue in New
Hampshire
um
the bill talks about deadlines it talks
about depositions talk about deposition
for a second a deposition is a
proceeding where both sides both sets of
lawyers get together in a room and a
witness is put under oath and that
witness's question it's recorded and
then transcribed it takes time to get
everybody in the same room and schedule
it it takes money to pay for that person
to record it and money to get it
transcribed you will spend tens of
millions of dollars if you give a
defendant the right to depose every
witness in every case It's Not Unusual
in one of my homicide cases to have a
potential 50 or 60 Witnesses if a
defendant has a right to depose each and
every one of those people the lawyers
will spend the next three to four months
just doing depositions and we'll blow
those speedy trial deadlines so it's
completely impractical to say to a
defendant you have the right to depose
every single witness but at the same
time we're going to set these deadlines
for Speedy Trial you can't have one or
the other
the way the law works now is every
defendant every every party in a
criminal case has an absolute right to
depose any expert witness case so if I
call an expert if the defense does they
have the absolute right to depose that
witness every other witness is that the
judge's discretion and the reason it's
different from civil cases where you
have more depositions is in a civil case
you don't have one side that's
generating all the evidence in a
criminal case we the state generate all
the evidence and we have to give it all
to the other side so there's far less of
a need to have depositions because we're
doing the interviews whether audio video
recorded we're we're creating the
evidence and handing it over to the
other side so there isn't the same need
for depositions like in a civil case
we're often there's just nothing there
to begin with so that's why the two are
very very different and many states
across the country criminal defendants
have no right to a deposition at all so
New Hampshire is actually ahead of the
curve on that but again if you're going
to give a defendant the right to depose
every single witness in every single
case he will clog the system down
because it will take me months to get
those depositions done before we can
even do the other things to prepare for
trial so have the actual opposite effect
of speeding things up it will actually
slow it down
I won't go through every single thing in
the bill Steve's going to cover some of
the other stuff but I want to talk about
the the honesty piece
it'd be great if everybody told the
truth but the reason that we're doing
criminal investigations is because
typically people aren't telling us the
truth
police officers who are undercover and
doing sting operations can't be required
to tell the truth otherwise they're not
going to be able to catch these folks
every undercover officer has to
masquerade as a customer or a drug
dealer we do sting operations where
somebody may tell us hey
this doctor is doing something wrong we
need to put somebody in to fake
themselves as a patient this would
preclude us from doing those basic
things in criminal investigation you
know typically if we go and announce
exactly who we are and why we're there
you know to a perpetrator they're not
just going to tell us what's going on so
sometimes we do have to use deception we
do have to lie we do have to Bluff
that's what we have to do that's and
that's one of the tools that the law
allows us to do
the Supreme Court has set limits on that
if police officers go too far in their
deception it can be a due process
violation and evidence can be suppressed
and charges can be dismissed so I don't
want you to think there aren't
guidelines out there or
guardrails there are but to say that you
know officers can't do that you will
undercut our ability to go after you
know the very people that you all want
us to go after out there so it's a tool
in the toolbox if it's abused there are
repercussions but we don't see that kind
of abuse here so this is generally I
just want to give you an idea those are
some of the general objections that we
have Steve will give you a few other
particular things and again happy to
answer any questions that you have about
this
thank you we referenced the speedy trial
I hear people talking about a murder
case that went on for three years It
just strikes me that
it would be unfathomable to me that a
murder case would be dismissed simply
because it wasn't tried fast enough
in this sets that deadline at
180 days from the arrest
which is a remarkably fast deadline and
as attorney strolls and said there's
already constitutional parameters for
Speedy Trial the superior court has a
speedy trial policy already
uh and dismissal is just such an extreme
sanction and cause in this case isn't
defined so it strikes me that a witness
not being available would certainly be
good cause to continue a case or or
exceed those timelines with reference to
Discovery it talks about Discovery
within 30 days of the date of arrest
judicial proceedings in New Hampshire
aren't commenced by an arrest they're
commenced by the filing of a complaint
in court there's ways that that can
occur without an arrest for example you
could be summonsed in lieu of an arrest
or you could be directly indicted with
no arrest so it doesn't make any sense
to to have the the starting date be the
arrest since that's not the beginning of
the criminal proceedings
the last sentence of that same section
in Discovery says the defendant shall be
entitled to a copy of their criminal
record prior to a bail hearing if the
state uses the criminal record at the
bail hearing that's a concept that was
sort of batted around by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court in an amendment
to rule 12 last year and the year before
the Supreme Court has a rules an
advisory committee on the rules
under docket
2020-006 they considered that proposal
there were a number of letters written
to the advisory committee on the rules
there was a public hearing there was a
subcommittee formed I know that the
subcommittee met several times they were
unable to come up with a consensus the
subcommittee actually
um
wrote three separate reports since they
weren't able to come up to a consensus
that then went before the entire Supreme
r-2022-0003 the Supreme Court also
sought public input there was public
input uh given in the Supreme Court and
after all that public input the Supreme
Court essentially found that that would
be an unworkable addition to the the
rules
and uh did not pass that with reference
to depositions as has been already said
a number of times there's already a
statute in New Hampshire that covers
depositions in criminal cases one of the
things that strikes me about the
deposition
this proposed bill is that it provides
the defendant with a greater entitlement
to a deposition than the state and I
don't understand why that would be uh
the current statute 517 13 entitles both
parties to depositions equally with
reference to the preservation of
evidence uh there's already
constitutional principles about the
preservation of evidence and again the
the remedy here is dismissal which
doesn't make sense because the Lost
evidence may be somewhat unrelated to
the actual crime itself
just for example if someone was arrested
for domestic violence and they were
brought back to the police station and
booked
the booking may have been completely
routine and yielded no evidence but if
the booking video itself was lost this
statute would require
um
would require dismissal and if not
dismissal then the fact finder could
make a negative inference against the
state related to that booking video with
reference to the DWI statute
Council or the defendant is notified of
their blood results I Believe by within
10 days and then they have 30 days to
pick up their second sample at the lab
so it's not that it's being destroyed
they're being notified you have a time
frame to pick it up and
uh attorney strolls uncovered the police
honesty again there's case law on that
the question's not the question about it
is whether a statement is knowingly
intelligently and voluntarily given the
question is not whether or not the
person was
maybe lied to prior to them giving that
statement
it's whether it's knowingly voluntarily
given
in terms of right to the media
attorneys are bound by the New Hampshire
rules of professional responsibility and
Rule 3.6 limit to lawyers ability to
make public statements prior to uh
and to some extent defendants already
possess a right to to speak to the media
I'm not aware of any law or limitation
that says if you're charged for the
crime you can't talk to the Press
if you're represented by Council I would
assume that any intelligent criminal
defense attorney would tell you
don't talk to anybody especially don't
talk to the Press because if you talk to
the Press it's going to get published
and then the prosecutor is going to see
that and the judge is going to see it
and ultimately may be used against you
this this statute the right to me it
doesn't actually Grant you a right to
speak to the Press what it does is
limits the judge's ability to issue
appropriate gag orders or to issue
appropriate limiting orders
um to ensure a fair trial
with reference to the exculpatory
evidence being provided to the grand
jury that
the United States Supreme Court actually
talked about this in the United States
versus Williams which you can find at
504 U.S 36 it's a 1992 case it's
actually sort of an interesting read
they point out that the grand jury is an
accusatory body not an adjudicatory one
so the grand jury is not deciding
whether or not the person is guilty or
not guilty the grand jury is assessing
whether or not there's enough an
adequate basis for bringing criminal
charges uh
in United States versus Williams it
talks about if you wanted a more
balanced approach instead of requiring
the prosecutor to present exculpatory
evidence which may not make any sense it
would make more sense to allow the
target of the investigation to come in
and present their side of the story
but that's been consistently rejected
because again a grand jury is not it's
not an adjudicatory body
with reference to the Penalty assessment
um in New Hampshire
there's a case it's State versus moral
you can find it at 123 New Hampshire 707
it's actually a 1983 case and they talk
about when someone's entitled to a jury
trial in New Hampshire
and the United the New Hampshire Supreme
Court says that
if an individual criminal defendant
essentially should be entitled to a jury
trial
when fines may be levied which are
greater than the amount constitutionally
entitling civil litigants to a jury
in New Hampshire
the Constitution part 1 article 20
provides that a civil litigant is
entitled to a jury trial if the amount
is fifteen hundred dollars or more
a Class B misdemeanor in New Hampshire
is up to a twelve hundred dollar fine
when you add a 24 penalty assessment you
get to one thousand four hundred and
eighty eight dollars
and I always wondered why it was 24
because the math is hard to do on 24 and
was like why didn't the legislature just
go to 25 because the math would be so
much easier and I suspect that the
reason the legislature didn't go to 25
percent is because a 25 penalty
assessment we make the total fine
fifteen hundred dollars
which again is the threshold for civil
jury trials which would then Grant
everybody charged with the Class B
misdemeanor in the city of New Hampshire
at the right to a jury trial
if you increase the penalty assessment
to 30 percent uh the maximum potential
penalty for a Class B misdemeanor would
be
1560 which again exceeds that fifteen
hundred dollar threshold and if you put
in a provision that there would be an
additional penalty assessment of fifty
dollars on every case for alcohol or
controlled drugs
that would make our current 24
penalty assessment exceed fifteen
hundred dollars in many Class B
misdemeanors so I think that the
unintended consequence of increasing the
penalty assessment would be somewhat
catastrophic on the circuit courts where
now everyone charged with Class B
misdemeanor would be entitled to a jury
trial as I had indicated earlier
attorney straussen and I had reached out
to the other County attorneys and I can
indicate that we've heard back from
attorney Halverson from Merrimack County
who opposes this bill Cheshire county
attorney Chris McDonald opposes the bill
Rockingham County attorney Pat Conway
opposes the Bill Carroll County attorney
and druzy opposes the bill of coax
County Attorney John McCormick poses the
bill Belknap County attorney Andrew
Livernois opposes the bill in Grafton
County attorney Marshall Hornick opposes
the bill we didn't hear back from anyone
saying they were in favor of it
so happy to answer any questions you
have about process or the Wake things
currently work or any other issues that
we see thank you um I have a couple of
quick questions so with regard to the
the blood
um
they have I believe you indicated 30
days they get a notice they have 30 days
to request it is it not true that they
oftentimes don't have Council assigned
so
for a first offense DWI you wouldn't be
entitled to a court appointed Council
because it's a Class B missed me so
you'd get arrested for DWI there'd be a
blood draw that night the blood would be
sent to the lab there's some delay in
testing the blood
after the blood is tested you're sent a
certified letter saying these are your
blood results and you have 30 days to to
pick it up
so it is absolutely possible that you
have not hired an attorney at that point
but that would be roughly
60 days after the incident so if
I've never tried to hire a DWI attorney
I was talking about more about a sign if
you were let's say second offense right
if it was the second offense I believe
that the
the current
State of Affairs is that a arraignment
is scheduled no less than 14 and no more
than 30 days out so you'd be in court
within 30 days of the offense you'd be
appointed counsel at that point
if the public defender's office had
enough attorneys I think after leaving
your arraignment you'd be able to call
the public defender's office and speak
to your attorney at that point so you
would definitely have the public
defender's office assigned I believe
um also I wanted to ask if you could
send those sites that you you listed um
absolutely just even if it's just the
links
um
could you tell me the the law currently
on on Federal Criminal depositions
if you know it yeah the federal standard
I don't know what the federal standard
is I mean it doesn't apply in New
Hampshire no I'm curious though
I know it's against state to state I
only know it from talking to other
practitioners some states that there's
no criminal depositions at all often we
hire people from other states they're
shocked to find out that we have
criminal depositions okay
um but in New Hampshire again mandatory
for experts and other side discretionary
as to others and and my last question
was um regarding the criminal
um the criminal record for bail
is the current state that a defendant
can be at a bail hearing and not know or
have his own own criminal record but the
the prosecutor does have it and they
don't get access to it right so
in New Hampshire if you're arrested and
the bail commissioner sets either cash
bail that you can't make a preventative
detention you're entitled to a bail
hearing within 24 hours
so you're transported from the police
station to the House of Corrections and
in New Hampshire they do most of those
hearings by video
so at the video arraignment especially
in Circuit Court the Circuit Court
prosecutor would get the file that
morning and do a presentation to the
court making a recommendation for bail
the Circuit Court prosecutors generally
would get the criminal record from the
police department and present that to
the court the defendant would be in the
house Corrections so it's absolutely
possible that the Circuit Court
prosecutor wouldn't be able to get a
physical copy of that criminal record to
the defendant in court
having said that the under the New
Hampshire rules of criminal procedure
rule 5e if a person is unrepresented at
that hearing they get a second hearing
upon request of counsel within 24 apps
so while it is absolutely possible that
the defendant doesn't have a copy of his
criminal record at that initial bail
hearing there's a number of safeguards
already in place so that they can have
subsequent hearings which they can
prepare for the concern that was brought
to the Supreme Court was that as a
circuit court prosecutor
we often didn't know who was
representing the defendant if anyone was
representing the defendant and it made
it very difficult to try and get these
records to the defendant the the
criminal records themselves are also
subject to a number of Rules from the
FBI's cjis so they can't be emailed they
have to be faxed it creates problems of
how to get this to the person
so
any question representative Rhodes thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
in regards to line 29 on the first page
about right to Media
it if the defendant is an example is
just in engulfed in say the glory of of
the horrificness because unfortunately I
believe that that happens sometimes what
would prevent the defendant if he has
you know say a a camera in front of him
from giving some details and the def in
the the victim's name or the
circumstances surrounding it
no nothing so
cross here in 25 years I've never seen a
court impose any kind of a gag order on
defendant ever
ever it's the lawyers who are subject to
the most professional conduct about what
we can say so we don't Prejudice the
defendant either side but the rules
obviously only address attorneys I don't
know of any of any provision that
addresses a defendant now a judge could
decide that the defendant is making
statements that prejudice someone's
right to a fair trial but that's pretty
rare again I can't it's never happened
that I've seen it in my time I can't
even think of a case of New Hampshire I
can think of many defendants in
Notorious cases including some my own
who stepped out and talked to the media
I didn't try to stop them I was happy
they were speaking so yeah I'm not sure
what that's trying to that's trying to
get at but quite frankly as a prosecutor
I'm perfectly happy if Defender wants to
talk to the news media nine times out of
ten it's very helpful for my case
it just is so
you know yeah I mean I had a defendant
that's his choice representative Bolden
thank you
um thanks for taking my question
um
I'm not gonna claim to know anything
near as much as you know
um unfortunately about the criminal
justice system but um it seems like the
the sponsor's intent maybe was to um
impart to cement uh some Supreme Court
decisions in state law and I know that
those can change over time
um and you know some did rather recently
regarding other topics um
would you have any opposition to maybe
amending the bill just to include the
areas that the sponsor was just trying
to convert Supreme Court decisions to
state law
yes because most all of this is also
addressed by our New Hampshire
Constitution
so there's just no need a lot of this
already exists in the New Hampshire
Constitution but what doesn't exist is
these set day deadlines and that again
is Impractical and unnecessary some
cases are quicker than others some move
slower than others so to set an
artificial deadline makes no sense what
makes sense is that what tip Gavin's the
parties get together and talk with the
judge about what they think a realistic
date or deadline is and sometimes
defendants want quicker trials but their
lawyers saying I can't be ready it makes
no sense so they have that they have
that Push Pull with their client or
their client's like I want a trial
yesterday and always like I can't get
the expert I can't do what I need to do
so that's where some of that tugging
comes
thank you I understand
um that a lot of the things included in
the bill haven't come out of Supreme
Court decisions but for example The
Mention Of exculpatory evidence isn't
that Brady is that the right one
um right also it's also cloudifying New
Hampshire Constitution about all groups
favorable so again it's already covered
there okay so are you so so you're
saying that that you feel that the um
Brady decision didn't affect New
Hampshire because it was already an
aspect of our constitution
the exculpatory evidence section is with
reference to the grand jury
which
there is no right to have exculpatory
evidence presented for the grand jury so
that's that's actually not a
constitutional
right in the correct so in the bill it
talks about
uh 604 11 would create exculp 3 evidence
provided to the grand jury a defendant
shall be entitled to the state
presenting all exculpatory evidence to a
grand jury
that's not a constitutional right
both the New Hampshire and U.S Supreme
Court have actually
said the exact opposite of that the
constitutional right is a trial right
where you go in and you have your guilt
earnestness decided and that's not what
representative saley
thank you Mr chair um so just out of
curiosity looking at the timelines for
this if if we were to theoretically
um meet the 90-day and 120 day and 180
day and we were just looking at State
trials not County we'll put those aside
for this question
how many additional attorneys attorney
support staff judges judges support
staff and defense attorneys would we
need to clear the current caseload in
that timeline let alone any new cases
I mean you would be talking
dozens and dozens and dozens of people I
mean
right now probably 90 percent or so of
cases are resolved with plea Bargains
imagine if you were to just reduce that
number by 10 percent
the number of personnel that you would
need would be astronomical and again if
your average defense attorney has
between 100 you know 100 100 or so cases
your prosecutors got 100 200 cases so
let's say you wanted to cut those in
half but that means you've got to double
the amount of those people and you're
gonna have to double the judges because
that means judges have got to deal with
more cases quicker so again you talking
tens of millions of dollars to try to
meet these deadlines and they're not
going to be realistic because the
lawyers are still not going to be ready
because if you've got to depose 50
Witnesses you can't meet those deadlines
welcome
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chair and thank you for all the
information really helpful I think the
only question I had was what Supreme
Court decision what was the Supreme
Court decision or decisions that dealt
with uh the guidelines for how police
could deceive uh someone that they
attained I don't remember the names of
the cases I mean I've looked at them but
they're typically you were Supreme Court
cases
so the the U.S Supreme Court case is
Fraser versus cup
it's
f-r-a-z-i-e-r versus cup c-u-p-p it's at
394 us 731 it's a 1969 case
and I believe it's also referenced in
New Hampshire and State versus wood
which you can be found at 128 New
Hampshire 739 I'd say 1986 case and to
be clear the court has said that while
officers may use deception or blocks to
get information from
suspects they can't do that to get a
Miranda okay right you can never do that
to get a breakup thank you very much
is anybody
thank you for your testimony and
the chair recognizes Attorney Richard
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
my intend is to talk about
um how this impacts Court resources
Court schedules
I think one of the one of the most
important resources the the court system
has is the daily docket the daily docket
is the calendar which governs what the
judge is going to be doing in a
courtroom on a particular day there are
seven and a half hours in a day in terms
of court time there's one judge that
judge can only do what's in the docket
in that day in that courtroom
um as you may remember when we gave our
initial presentation if you take Concord
circuit court for example Monday
morning's docket is already full that's
going to be arraignment it's going to
either be video or live arraignments so
that duck gets full Monday afternoon's
already full
Friday morning's already full Friday
afternoon's already full we have a lot
of dockets that sort of have things that
are already in it so those dockets are
not available
um so
so what
a Clerk's job is is to balance and and
the judge's job is to balance a
remarkable number of things
um they're balancing constitutional
rights speedy trial uh whatever it may
be they're balancing uh physical harm to
people uh emergency domestic violence
emergency petition
they're balancing the age of cases civil
cases that are pending in the courthouse
they're balancing mandatory deadlines
that are set by the legislature in
statute those have to be met landlord
tenant cases they have uh I think it's
for 10 days uh after the after the uh
petition is filed they're just a
remarkable number of things that go into
putting together that schedule and one
of them is absolutely the right of
speedy trial and that is a factor in
terms of ensuring that a criminal case
when it's filed meets those
constitutional requirements of speedy
trial
when it in preparation for for today's
hearing we did ask our judges you know
when was the last time a speedy trial
became sort of the driving force of of
uh of a dismissal
um
almost none of them could re even recall
it resulting in a dismissal there were a
couple that that did
um in in over the last 10 years but
there were a couple but it is not
something that and they all said that's
something I would remember because it
just doesn't happen
um so the the
by imposing a 90-day 180 day deadline is
one more factor in terms of consuming
what is an incredibly valuable resources
resource not to meet now a
constitutional deadline but to meet a
statutory deadline and it said we have
statutory deadlines this would not be a
constitutional deadline this would be a
a statutory deadline that we now have to
work into that schedule
anytime you take a resource which is
that quartz docket and you put something
on it that means something else is not
going on it that means something a small
claims case that is waiting for somebody
to get in front of a judge is not going
to be hurt that's one of the things we
try to balance we want those cases to be
heard and we want those to get in front
of a judge the more things we have that
are required by Statute
the fewer the harder it is to get to
those things that we simply do not have
a deadline built into it and we try to
have time available for those things
that don't have a deadline built into it
so I think this
proposal while it may sound like okay
this will speed things up it's a speedy
trial thing the net result of having
more and more core or statutory
deadlines is to actually slow down the
process it gives one less thing that the
that the court can take into
consideration when scheduling and
figuring out what's going to be next on
that docket at 10 o'clock on Tuesday
morning it's it's just one more way of
saying okay something else is simply not
going to get reached Tuesday morning at
nine o'clock
um as you heard before we don't actually
track the arrest date we can't track 90
days from an arrest date we don't know
it's not part of our system uh it's it's
not it's not a way in which we track
anything so taking 90 days for us to do
something within 90 days of something we
don't track is uh is very difficult
um
the other aspect of this is we currently
have as you all know a public defender
shortage
um appointed we say you're entitled to a
public defender that's the easy part it
then goes to the public defender's
office and they also have an extremely
full caseload for them to file an
appearance in some places can be quite a
while they're not filing at the day
after
the court orders it so that factors into
when is the case going to get scheduled
when is the public defender filing the
appearance in that case
I'm going I'm not going to you all have
tremendous stamina
um
moving on to part two of the of the
build which talks about the penalty
assessment
um the first part of it talks about
there would be a fifty dollar case on
every k a fifty dollar chart penalty
assessment on every case involving a
charge for an alcohol or controlled drug
offense
that's not the way we we don't have a
list of everything that is a controlled
uh
drug offense or an alcohol offense it
needs to reference a a chapter a section
or a title of an RSA we we don't sort of
have this this way of saying you know
this would be a controlled drug offense
some are obvious some of them are less
obvious that doesn't tell us what
statutory sections or chapters or titles
are entitled to that new
um penalty assessment the penalty
assessment then says that it would be
provided to the judicial branch
Information Technology fund which is a
fund that does exist and it does a
percentage of penalty assessment does
come into our I.T fund and then it says
for use by the state crime lab we have
nothing to do with the State Crime Lab
it's an executive branch agency not a
judicial branch agency we don't know
what to do about that line it just
simply doesn't make any sense in terms
of the transmittal of money to something
that we don't have any control over
so in closing with regard to the sort of
substance of of this
to provide this new statutory deadline
would have a a simply a huge impact on
the Court's ability to to schedule and
control its own docket and we do ask
that that this um
will be voted down itl thank you uh with
that I'd be happy to answer any
thank you for your testimony today thank
you very much for your time tonight is
there anyone else wishing to testify
this bill is not testified
um before I close the hearing I would um
encourage the sponsor if you heard
anything today that you'd like to rebut
that send an email to the committee